good morning everyone and welcome to
this meeting of development control
committee a at mid-south district
council
can i first of all just remind us some
of remind everyone some of the domestic
arrangements for today
i please ask you to ensure your
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking
and that you do not interrupt other
speakers members are reminded not to use
the messaging or
chat function during the meeting unless
it is to report a pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest
or to notify the chair that you wish to
make a proposal
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open by other team chats and that if you
are contacted by a third party during
the applications
you should please bring this to the
attention of our legal advisor
uh if you are attending to meet uh
please do not uh
if you are attending to if you are
attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt you will be
asked to leave so we ask you please
don't do that
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair of the
meeting by using the hands up function
and we will be using the e-voting for
this meeting
if you're experiencing any poor
connection issues which i know some of
us have this morning in the first
instance please just try turning off
your camera
if this does not work maybe turn off all
incoming video
these options are on the three dots at
the top of the bar
on the main information bar can i also
please remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live on the
internet
and will be capable of repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting
is recorded and except except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make any representations to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed and
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
um just like to introduce some of the
people we have here with us today
so we have ian de prez who's our legal
advisor good morning ian
we have robert carmichael who's the
governance officer
uh morning robert philip isbell chief
planning officer
stephen stroud who's the
strategic projects and delivery manager
gemma walker and john pate mcgee who are
the area planning
managers then we have the case officers
that we presented today bradley heffer
and jasmine wyatt so welcome to you
and i'm glad that we have sam harvey and
jason skelton have joined us from
suffolk county council's highways and
floods team
the ward members for the applications
are uh john whitehead
uh council sorry councillor john
waterhead council tim pasmore councillor
mike norris encounter
uh stephen phillips and council daniel
pratt um
you may not at mid-south district
council the local councillors
may speak on an item before them but may
not vote
okay um i'm going to move to the agenda
please agenda item number one is
apologies for absence
and substitutions i'll now ask the
governance officer to roll call the
members present
thank you chair and if mems could just
respond with their presence this morning
so councillor rachel lieberman president
councillor john field
president councillor hicks president
councillor sarah mansell president
councillor john matheson
president council richard mayer
president councillor dave miller
president and counselor tim passmore
president we're all
here thank you very much uh agenda item
number two
is to receive declarations of pecuniary
or non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any that members wish to
declare if so would you like to put your
hand up
okay none received uh yes sorry uh
council
madison and councillor field yeah for
for the
sake of openness etc um i
i do live in the uh in needham market
but um i am at least half a mile away
from the site and can't actually see it
from here that's fine thank you and
council field yes
just that the whitten area was is when
my county council award
okay thank you that that's both noted
okay uh agenda item number three is
declarations of lobbying
um i've i'm guessing we've all had the
same councilor mayor
yes i've been lobbied on both
is there any member let's do it the
other way is any member that hasn't been
lobbied on both
nope we've all had lobbied on both
okay so that's for the record thank you
very much sorry chair i haven't
i've only been lobbied on seven-day
counsellory burn here okay
thank you councillor ben uh move on to
agenda item number four
declarations of personal site visits are
there any
uh the members wish to declare
nope okay next agenda item
is the uh confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting that were held on the 20th
of january
um are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes that members
wish to raise if not could i ask for a
proposal for the minutes please
counselor mueller thank you thank you
and a seconder is that councillor mayor
happy to prove to chair thank you um
governance officer will now conduct an
electronic vote
thank you
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the modern.gov app
where they will see the uh in the top
right hand corner the plus sign
and please go to attendance voting and
if
the and then we'll bring up the list the
vote is now in progress in the light
blue bar across the screen
so just waiting on there we are so
thank you chair that is seven votes for
with one abstention
thank you very much okay agenda item
number
uh sorry the minutes of the meeting have
been confirmed and they'll be signed off
at the next practical opportunity
thank you members uh next agenda items
agenda item number six to receive the
notifications
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme uh have we
received any please
none receive sure okay well that takes
us straight on to the schedule of
planning applications that are before us
today
uh the first item is uh dc 20
03704 land west of old norwich road
whitton ipswich
um i now invite the case officer uh
bradley heifer to introduce the
application to committee
bradley over to you
thank you very much chair um i'll just
share my screen so you can
see my presentation
can i just ask whether you can see yeah
we can see perfectly
excellent well good morning members
ladies and gentlemen
this application is a reserve matters
proposal
for 190 dwellings on a site leicester
west of old norwich road whitton is an
application that came to you
at the previous mitsuffake committee on
the 20th of january and was deferred
this is an aerial map showing the site
and
the location in relation to the a14
which you can see on the left hand side
here
and the old norwich road on the right
hand side of the site
basically sits in the middle and to the
top
we have clayton and
there's um industrial state and retail
area
to the south of the site um and whitton
which is on the edge
of ipswich in in this position here
the constraints map shows um there's
limited constraints on the site in all
honesty what it does show obviously is
the the red
sorry the black line that that uh
divides
um ipswich from our district
um and this abuts on its southern side
as you can see
there's also a listed building up in the
top right hand corner
which is well away from the the
application site
um the other heritage um asset
in the area is not actually shown here
but it's um
a conservation area which is actually
located
on this t-junction within whitton itself
which is
within ipswich borough
this is the red line application site
that we're considering today
um as part of the application that went
to planning sorry
went to appeal
the application was approved to appeal
as you may recall from a previous
presentation
there was a parameters plan that was
identified by the
inspector which basically identified
what could go where
on this particular site and this really
has formed the basis of the discussions
and and the submission that's before you
today
just quickly to go through that
hopefully you can see the legend which
is on
on the side here but that indicates
roughly where the um
residential development would go areas
of strategic landscaping
within the site a large area of open
space
and an area of access sorry a point of
access to serve the development
i'd also draw attention to something
which i didn't do last time which is
within the area of open space it does
specifically identify
that suds would be located within that
within this area here
this is a site master plan of the
reserve matters proposal which basically
interprets
the plan you've just seen
and when this went to committee last
time members deferred consideration of
this application in order that a number
of issues could be looked at
these included triple parking provision
boundary treatment for a buffer area
the designer plot one the roundabout
access proposal
chimneys heating pedestrian connectivity
and such details and i'll go through
these proposals sorry these issues in
the order i've just
identified so starting first with the
parking plan
the revised scheme which you have before
you today
shows the admission of all triple
parking
on the site bar one um
bar one uh instance which is this plot
here
and hopefully you can see that where
there's a triple parking
as i've said in the revised sorry in the
amended
report
sorry uh as i said in the revised report
if this is to be planned out completely
then that would mean that the whole of
this area
would have to be rejigged and in terms
of a response in planning terms we were
happy with that
we were happy with the way this works uh
as townscape
so we thought that that was a reasonable
response and limiting that down
to one particular element
the boundary treatments i showed this
plan before
which and the reason i showed this
before was to highlight
the um the acoustic
fencing that would be along the boundary
here because obviously it butts the a14
on um the the western side
um but in terms of
what's happened since the deferral um
the landscape buffer now
is an area that is completely contained
and you'll see this line here is close
boarded fencing
with a single point of access which
would be locked so that whole area would
be
um basically locked from any access
whatsoever
um the other things to point out
is that the um is proposed as part of
this
um overall permission that there would
be a management plan in place
where this would be maintained as part
of the open space for the
the overall site and i understand that
discussions have taken place with local
residents
and it has been agreed in principle that
the the um
the sort of maintenance of this
particular part would be reviewed every
two weeks
so there would be a two weekly
inspection of this particular
part of the area so it can become a
dumping ground although as i've said in
my report it's so well overlooked
i doubt that's likely to happen in any
event the other thing i understand is
the case is that
where you've got new dwellings that butt
onto the landscape buffer
um there would be an element within the
deeds which would preclude
owners or occupiers from creating
gateways
into this space from their gardens
so again there's a further control so it
would it would literally be a landscape
buffer that is
completely contained
um this shows the sections of the
landscape area i've just been talking
about the landscape buffer
so you can see the new development here
and here the new dwellings and basically
in in section you'll see fencing which
would enclose the area we've just been
talking about
and this is the position of the nearby
uh residential development that exists
on old marriage road
the other thing that you can see on this
drawing is
the revisions that have taken place in
relation to plot one
which is basically handing the dwelling
and the garage
before the application came to you the
dwelling was roughly in the position
where the garage is
that's been swapped over the pitch of
that garage has actually
been lessened and there is a drawing to
show that further on in the presentation
but that's been revised in response that
organization of that plot has been
revised in response to members
comments this is the junction detail
which was
presented last time which shows the
provision
of a roundabout arrangement and as i
said before
this is the line of
cyclist access through the junction
heading north
um there has been discussion about this
with the highway authority
since the deferral and
the latest aversion i understand of the
discussions
you'll note varies from the previous
plan in so far as there's now
a line for pedestrians to come sorry for
cyclists
traveling south uh a separate line on
the highway
so they've actually got their own
carriageway there um or part of the
carriageway
and also the crossing positions have
been amended
so they've been pushed back further
along the road which i understand again
is a response to to safety concerns
but certainly the arrangement of the
access that's being
you're being asked to consider hasn't
changed and
as chair advised we have got um highway
uh engineers here who could advise you
further on that
if necessary um the permeability plan
which was discussed one of the issues
for deferral
this highlights the permeability as i've
said in my report
the a14 acts as a barrier really to
permeability that
to the west and to the north
the provision is along old norwich road
public rights way
the existing public right-of-way to the
south is along this boundary which is
the shared boundary with ipswich borough
and you'll note that it's proposed to
link through
desire lines and routes across the open
space
in order to link through with that and
of course there's the existing access
vehicle access which pedestrians and
cyclists can use of course
this plan also shows pink lines and
green lines
where pedestrians can permeate through
the site and not just
follow the actual carriages
carriageways the main carriageways there
is
a permeable route through which is
something that we would support
in planning terms
this is the landscape master plan and
the reason
i've put this one on there is primarily
to show you well obviously the
landscaping proposals the overall site
but in terms of this issue which was
the uh drainage basin um
the location of that as i said before in
the parameters plan
was was identified as being as part of
the parameters plan
and i think there are sound reasons as i
understand it for locating the drainage
in that
or basin in that particular location uh
because of the
the site topography
this plan here this cross section here
gives you an idea of what's
the current situation and what would be
the situation in relation to
the the drainage basin if the
development were approved you'll note
the red line here is the existing
level of the land the green line is
the profile of the basin and the blue
line here
is the worst case scenario modeling
in relation to uh flooding
so you know in a in a 1 in 100 year
biblical event to give a term um the
the basin could actually uh cope with
that and obviously the funding
would protect that from the the nearest
dwelling
i've got um another plan which will show
that in perhaps
easier detail to understand this is the
building sorry dwelling um on old
norwich road
which you can see here and the profile
of the bund
and also the line of the drainage
so again in terms of the the drainage
we're content that the location of the
basin
is in the correct position and we're
also content
that the um you know the way that the
basin has been designed
um is able to cope with flooding events
the other thing i should point out and
as
has been something that's been mentioned
in a number of representations
is this area here to the front of the
site which
um is prone to being waterlogged it is
an
area of this particular site that um
you know does stand has a certain level
of standing water i know a number of
residents are concerned
that this element of the development
could be exacerbated by
um the proposals to drain in this
location here
um i think that that has been considered
by our drainage engineer
um as part of the overall consideration
of this
proposal um and it's it's
uh considered that this may have
actually occurred at the time
that old norwich road went in um
and so there was probably a backup crate
at some time
whereas previously the drainage would
have gone across
um from that point to that point whether
that's true or not
i can't give you a definitive answer but
in any event
um this area here um notwithstanding the
proposal to put the drainage basin in
it's felt that this would be um sorry
this
this feature has been considered as part
of that overall element
and indeed in terms of the location uh
sorry the landscaping proposals
um it's the the planting of this the
proposed planting of this
would reflect the the the sort of
wetland status of that particular
that particular part of the site
um i'll just go through these again
you've seen these drawings before but
they've been updated with the revised
location
sorry with the revised layout this is
the electrical
electric charging plan um the red dots
are basically the dots that will be
provided in each garage there will be
infrastructure in order for residents to
provide their own connection to
electric vehicles there's three standing
elements
which are serving the shared parking
areas
and there's also on these particular
units here
there will be provision on the flank
walls
the affordable housing plan um
this shows the distribution of uh
affordable housing the the blue units
are
affordable for rent and the shared
ownership are
the redder units you can see there but
the distribution importantly has been
improved since the initial submission
um and has been agreed by the strategic
housing team
um the character area plan briefly this
is to demonstrate that there would be a
variety of character areas across the
site
the lighter area which is known as the
street would be the more
formally arranged development and the
darker green would be the um
the area where it would be less formal
looser arrangement so there is a there
is that
change across the site which again we
consider to be important in planning
terms
um these are updated street scenes um
the things
that you should note in particular to
these
is the the lack of chimney features
there's no chimneys proposed on any of
the dwellings now
um and also
in this in relation to this one this
does show the
the latest iteration of development on
plot one and you'll notice
the the pitch of the garage has been
dropped down
one of the other reasons for deferral
was in relation to heating
of the units um you'll have noted from
the
papers that the um
they've put in a a sustainability
statement
which is basically identifying that the
dwellings would be heated by gas
but also in terms of sustainability
generally
they would follow a fabric first
approach
whereby trying to design out
heat loss and issues like that
the the build stage rather than adding
things later on
that's not to say of course that later
on occupiers
couldn't add things like photo photo
voltaic cells and things
over time which could probably be done
in a lot of cases under
permitted development i'll quickly run
through
the house types where you do see
chimneys
please ignore them because they've all
been removed now
as you can see it's a traditional um
architectural approach
that's been taken on the site which we
think is wholly appropriate
given the site context
there are instances of bungalows single
story development so
there is a variety of forms on the site
and just very quickly in relation to uh
plot one
that is the unit that will be erected on
plot one
the only windows that would face towards
block one would be two windows
on the flank elevation at first floor
level but they would both serve
um an ensuite and a bath and therefore
would be obscure glazed
so we're happy with that in relation to
overlooking impacts
um as you see it's all a
fairly traditional design
this is a quick look down the road
old norwich road you can see the the
the we can't fail to notice the pylons
which are one of the key
elements within the landscape and that's
looking up
norwich road towards the bus gate
and this is a sweep across the site so
you can see
or hopefully be able to perceive the the
changes in level as you look towards and
we can see my dot there
is is towards the a14 um again
there's the um the pylons and they will
cross the open space provision
uh rather than sit over um proposed
residential development
uh sorry it's on the wrong way um in the
background there you can see
the northern boundary of the site which
is the um
existing uh band of trees
um and that's the dwelling um which
plot number one would sit the dwelling
you can see here
plot number one would sit adjacent to
that roughly in that position
again another view of old norwich road
this
is a gap as i said last time this is a
gap that's between
two houses on old norwich road and does
offer access to the rear of the site
sorry to the applications tonight it's
not proposed to utilize this as part of
the um
the the planning application it's not
shown within the red line
and if you recall talking about the
buffer area at the back
this would be um blocked off by close
boarded fencing
in this position as part of that overall
contained area
um there's a final view across the site
and that's roughly
looking across where the access road
would go in
so i'll leave you with the master plan
the other thing i would draw your
attention to before i finish my
presentation
is the late late paper sheet
which summarises um some of the changes
i've been talking about
well sorry it summarizes some of the
discussions that have been
taking place just to reiterate there was
an issue with a
archaeology and that has now been
resolved in terms of the approach
that's going to be taking on the site um
affordable housing provision
um the distribution of that has been
agreed as i said
uh previously and i think it's important
to identify
that the applicant has undertaken
further consultation
uh with councillors uh parish
and uh local residents following the
deferral in order to discuss these
issues
so they haven't just come in completely
cold i think that
they have made attempts to actually you
know engage with local residents which
we think is
particularly helpful and lastly rather
than the summary of conditions
which was produced in my original report
if you look at the table paper
um i've produced the conditions in full
um
so that you can be clear the ones we
would recommend
in the event that you were willing to
accept the
the officer recommendation but i'll
leave it there
and obviously happy to take any
questions thank you
thanks can you just remind me how many
triple parking places there were
uh before and what it's gone down to
because it's gone down to one
what what were the numbers before i i
think jerry it was about 30 or
33 34. right okay thank you
okay uh questions uh
on the presentation today do we have
anyone else
uh yeah we have some hands that are
going up okay okay i'm
for some reason not getting any hands so
um okay i'd say they're going up and i'm
not getting them in the order
so i apologize so i'll just go in the
order i'm seeing and i apologize if it's
not the correct
order uh cancer ceremony burn
uh thank you chair um i i would like to
ask the uh
county council highways representation
representative a question if that's
okay um uh about the
uh roundabout arrangement for cyclists
um i i would very much appreciate it if
the highways
officer is able to explain to me
why they believe that a roundabout
with a left turn lane specifically
drawn on the road for cyclists is the
best
option to go on the national cycle
network
route where the majority of cyclists
will be going
straight on along old norwich road
effectively turning right
thank you
sam welcome good morning good morning
chair yes
thank you council mansell the
at the moment the drawing is showing a a
cycle lane on to the roundabout but this
can be
shortened so is it um anybody who wish
to
to go forward straight on they can
obviously um take ownership of the lane
as as we know with cycling proficiency
this is what we want to do when we uh
cycling uh to turn right or go straight
on on a roundabout
you do want to own your lane so i unders
i can see
um your point about this lane being
painted on so this is something that we
could
uh reduce so as the the cyclist feels
that they have the ability to go into
that lane
i come back um with a further question
if that's allowed
of course was any consideration made to
creating an off-road shared
pavement bicycle cycle way thing
um approaching the roundabout um
so that uh cyclists would
um effect i mean if they if they're not
confident enough to
hold the right-hand lane of a roundabout
which many children might not be
um they could actually go onto the
pavement and
have a dedicated cycle crossing on the
spur road into the
estate uh and then back onto the
pavement again
and then join the old nodes road ra um
lane again further north i was any
consideration
made to putting that in instead of the
painted online
yes uh thank you so this is something
that we've been talking to the designers
for
during the section 278 agreement we were
looking at whether or not we can't there
is enough room
obviously there's enough room on the
south
uh west side because that's within their
ownership is the concern would be would
there be enough length um
in the the northwest side but it is
something that we are looking at to
allow a cyclist to be able to get into a
shared cycle
route to use the crossing point um
and and continue straight on um we've
we've obviously discussed
about having the route coming southwards
uh their own cycle route within um
sort of like a bypass which is easy
enough to do for the southbound
but we are looking at the north band
with our design for
the detailed design for section 278
so this design that that um uh bradley
has
is sharing now um although we're we're
being asked to
agree this planning application are you
telling me
that this plan is still subject to
negotiation
in other words we might not get what we
see on the on the picture now
it's minor details uh would be
when we're doing this section 278 this
this site has already gone through uh of
stage two safety audit
so any changes would have to go through
the order again
um but there are some minor details as
in we're looking at and exploring
putting the cycling after the deferral
looking at putting cycling onto the
footwear
but when it comes to the detailed design
in principle
it will be in principle what's
shown on screen but there will be minor
details that could change when we do the
actual design detailed design
which is standard i mean that happens on
all applications
that's not unique to this yeah okay
thank you councillor eben
thank you chair um thank you bradley for
your presentation
i've got two questions if i may um
firstly
was consideration given of having air
source heat pumps given that gas boilers
are going to potentially be
banned in 15 years time
and um secondly um with regards to
suds and water retention the
i understand the suds features have been
modeled in relation to the 100 year
rainfall event
but we're we're getting more of those at
the moment so
um is is there a you know what what's
the confidence
rate really of that because it's the um
flood engineer says
100 in 100 year rainfall event including
climate change and i'd have thought and
on this
there seems to be a lot of water
attention on this area already
with the pressure of the existing houses
it's going to be far greater so
just the sort of confidence level of
that 100 year
comment thank you very much chair
yes thank you cancer rebound on the
point of the air source heat pumps
um then the uh the late the papers are
part of the bundle now i think that
it does identify that the air source
heat pumps were considered
or have been considered by bellways on a
number of their schemes
and i think at this particular point in
time they've been discounted because
they don't think that they're actually
as practical in achieving what they want
to do with regard to
sustainability savings
as the approach they're taking now which
is fabric first but does include the use
of the um
the gas boilers i mean obviously they
might be able to give you
some more information on that but that's
certainly my interpretation of what's
been provided
in relation to suds um as far as
we can be certain and the advice we have
been given
um certainly we feel that the approach
has been taken here
is the most appropriate for the site um
but we do have
i'm mindful that that's probably not
enough information for you so
we do have jason skilton here perhaps
can
provide some more information in
relation to that particular point if
that would be helpful
um thank you bradley i i think i would
because you know there's obviously
existing
issues and then adding the housing on
top extra pressures
thank you jason if we could bring you in
please
uh morning chair monster i can't beat
you ben um so yes so
the the the design strategy for the
southward drainage meets national
and local policy with regard to uh
utilizing infiltration on site
the applicant has provided um
infiltration test results and they've
actually provided additional
infiltration test results to show that
the soils are permeable in that location
as bradley heffer did point out as part
of the appeal
we are limited where we can actually put
the surface water drainage
features so we've had to utilize the
best use of the land
with the constraints both from the
appeal the overhead
power lines gas main and also the
topography
with regard to the design standard of
the hundred year plus climate change
what national planning policy the
non-technical guidance says
is there should be no above ground
flooding in the 1 in 30-year event
and no off-site flooding in the 1 in 100
plus climate change
now what the applicant has actually done
on this is actually designed to a higher
standard
so that all the water will be retained
on site for the one in 100 year plus
climate change
what we also do as part of the technical
standards
is the applicant has to provide various
safety measures with regard to the
hydraulic calculations
and they also provide an additional
volume of storage called freeboard
on top of the hundred year plus climate
change uh water level
thank you very much and that's really
helpful thanks thank you eric
phillipsburg i think did you want to
come in on on a point just been made
uh just to go back to councillor mance's
point about cycling if i may chair
and apologize i mean it's important to
bear in mind this is a reserve matters
application
so we are dealing with details rather
than the planning application per se and
obviously
the conditions that we've recommended to
you today are in addition to those which
are listed in the appeal decision which
is in your bundle um
in terms of what's being described
around the uh
cycling navigation around the roundabout
i mean i think it's also important
as council manson will know the the
advice of british cycling and
other organizations is very much for
cyclists to dominate the lanes so that
traffic is aware
of them and slowed down so there's a
definite advantage to that
if the uh if members consider this
there's
uh something to explore around uh the
provision of cycling
uh a cycling space adjacent to the
crossing that seems to me within the
territory of a condition on the reserve
matters consent rather than
something that uh needs to trouble the
committee for a prolonged period thank
you jim
thank you very much okay we'll go back
to
questions and um next up i have
counselor matheson thank you chair yeah
i'm glad the floods engineers here
because that that was also my
my concern um could we look at that
cross
section uh of that um that bradley put
up
showing the sustainable drainage basin
because it it looked to me as if the the
existing house in
in the old norwich road was was actually
lower
um and so i really wanted to be
absolutely sure that the
the water from the new development is
actually going to
not go to the um
to flood the house but to or to go into
the basin
we could i'm sure these things have been
thought about but it does actually look
that way
um there was a there was another one
with a line
showing the levels yeah that one that's
the one
um yeah that that um
that existing can't quite see it
neighboring house
i'm not sure which house that is on the
not but on the north shore but
that that one looks at risk
on the section
jason do you want to come in just on on
that particular
point certainly can uh morning
counseling medicine um
so with regards to this this is a
reserved matters application so we're
actually looking at the
from our perspective we're looking at
the location and landscaping
um the actual exceedance routing as
we we would term it with regard to the
basin and where it would
flow out would be considered as part of
the discharge of conditions which
we're currently looking at the moment
the exceedance event would be of course
greater than the one in 100 year plus
climate change
and at the additional free board that's
been built into
the uh surface water drainage design so
that what that means in
in reality um is it would be a truly
biblical event to actually make this
basin
um over top the flood exceedance route
would be direct which is away from any
existing
um properties or any new properties and
would be looking to
discharge into what we call safe
locations
um okay thank you very much
okay at councillor field
thank you so much to stick with the same
subject but um a couple of questions
looking at that profile plan the base of
the house sits at
35.2 meters and the
base of the water in the basin not the
top of it the bottom of the basin sits
at 35.2 meters
and the land as surrounding is up at
about
36. and the top of the water is at 37.
i always thought walter ran downhill
not up so can i ask presumably the rest
of this site
is substantially higher than the drawing
we're looking at
i'm sure that must be so but it could be
confirmed
the question really next is about the
water table that sits below that ground
level
i'm informed that those houses suffer
from problems such as
their um current sewage arrangements
aspects filling up with water and
that has been getting significantly
worse of late
i just would like some reassurances that
you're aware of where the water table is
and that um
you you have that all correctly
engineered
so i think that's the questions for
jason
i do have one other question which you
really need let's should we take those
then we'll come back
uh morning tesla field um so with
regards
as i said this is a reserve matters
application so we're predominantly
looking at the landscaping and location
of that the uh groundwater levels have
been looked at
and they would be what we call um below
the
minimum unsaturated zone from where
infiltration would take part
so the environment agency and serious
suds manual both have a different
figure that there should be what we call
an unsaturated zone below any
infiltration designs of at least a meter
a groundwater moderate monitoring has
been looked at on this as part of the
the the boreholes and has been shown to
be significantly deeper
with regard to historical um suspects
you'll be
finding that most of those have actually
been dug deeper than modern
um infiltration devices and hence
probably why
the local residents are are suffering
from um
groundwater actually coming into those
old cesspits designs
that's why on modern cesspit designs and
i'm not an
expert they're generally a lot shallower
than they are
are back in sort of um pre-date the the
um sort of the 1990s
philip did you want to come in on that
point before we go back to john for a
follow-up question uh
no chairman actually no it's an old hand
i should have taken that
okay john back to you right just the one
other things about
um the the discussion of heat pumps and
fabric
first i was just going to question
the way it was said it implies that
fabric first
precludes the use of
non-fossil fuel methods of heating
houses like heat pumps
i thought fabric first just meant you
could adequately insulate the place and
provide
perhaps things like triple glazed
windows but that there's still
considerable freedom
as to how you might choose to heat it am
i wrong
yes thank you cancer field um i think
that
what i was trying to badly answer last
time was the fact that um
as part of the overall um approaches to
sustainable
heating and development um the use of
air source heat pumps
has been considered not just on this
development but it's been considered in
other developments by the developer
but they have chosen to actually uh
not use that technology at this point
that's not to say i assume
that they wouldn't consider that in the
future but i think within the papers
there's an explanation as to why they
think it's not appropriate to use that
at this particular time
and why they think that the um the
heating method
that they're using now which is the gas
methodology
is the most appropriate um but as i say
i'm not sure there's much more i can say
on that particular point
john you could always ask the applicant
when they okay
i'll think of that thank you thank you
councillor mayor
thanks chip um sorry to go over
old ground again but i am concerned
about this suds and my question
is the current location for the suds
am i right in understanding that that is
has been selected a because the
inspector said he want to go there
and be because there are power lines
over the top
is there anything preventing that suds
moving further down towards the road
where it wouldn't threaten
the um the house because it's all very
well say it's once in a hundred years
but if you're lying in bed when there's
a thunderstorm outside and you know full
well the suds is filling up
you wouldn't you'd have trouble sleeping
wondering whether
it's just 100 year events going to see
my house flood so
is there no scope for that suds to move
further towards the road
thank you councillor oh sorry jason um
just in terms of the
the principle um um
to reiterate the the plan that was shown
the parameters
plan did identify that a suds feature
would be going in this
location um as part of that
and as i say i think the actual final
location of that
and something was picked up discussed
previously
is the topography of the site the way
the site works
because i think that in terms of the
topography um it does
this a14 at the top it does fall this
way
but it also falls this way so therefore
this is the higher ground this is the
lower ground and in terms of an
infiltration and suds location
um this would be deemed
unless jason's got another view to be
the most appropriate
location for that basin to be uh
located but well i'll wait to hear what
late uh sorry what jason says
is it not true that um towards the
bottom of the site i was talk we were
told that
that that tends to flood towards the um
the road does that not suggest that's
downhill
um well i think that yes the the site
does go this way
it falls this way but it also falls this
way so it's not
just a a simple curve that way and this
is on
higher ground than this i understand
that the the actual topography works
so that it is in the lower location but
in terms of
this area here as i said before i think
that prior to this development
being proposed historically there's
always been
an element of wetland if you can call it
that
at the frontage of this site and what
what has caused that
um i don't think it's been entirely uh
established
whether it's um the way that this road
has actually blocked the drainage
um route traditional drainage routes or
historic
drainage routes across the land falling
that way south
east um or whether something else has
actually occurred here but there is a
wetland
location here um but in terms of
whether this bowl should be in this
location here
as i say i'm given to understand from
the investigations that have been taking
place
up until this point which has been over
a long period of time
this is the most appropriate location
for that particular feature
but as i say i'll wait to hear what
jason says
thank you bradley uh morning counseling
mayor um
so yeah as you've rightly pointed out we
do have some various con
constraints um set on on us with regard
to
the location of the base and uh the
topography the overhead power lines
there's also a gas main that
that runs partly through the site and
also what the planning inspector decides
is
the the the allocation of the land um
the other factor that actually dictates
where the infiltration basin goes is
actually the test results from from the
circuit test that was
undertaken by the applicant so the
applicant undertook
a a number of infiltration tests both to
the outline
application stage and additional testing
that i've asked for
and actually the location of the basin
has proven
is based on where the best infiltration
rates
are um uh are present now with regard to
the wet area in in front of the
old norwich road historically there's
been some ambiguity over why it's
been wet there's been reports that there
has been historically
leaks from possible water supplies um
there may be the damning effect
of the building of the old norwich road
which has caused
the water to not be able to take its
natural flow price across the site
but with regard to the basin it does
naturally um
is naturally in an area that would
capture
the water from the higher land
did you want to come back cancer man i
need to
question we've been driven by
uh a plan inspector who is he a drainage
engineer
was it you know would if he have had all
the information that's available now
when he made that or
she made that decision
chairman can i go can i comment on this
um so
inspectors uh rely on the evidence
provided to them
chairman um and if you look at the
uh appeal decision uh which is in your
bundle
uh you can obviously see the range of
issues that they in particular
considered uh
and i think within that you'll see
there's uh quite a lot of consideration
given to surface water drainage
now i don't know let me just looking at
the qualifications of the inspector
they're not given but i believe philip
major
who was the inspectors is a planner
rather
an engineer i trade um and he will
relied upon the
evidence and advice given by witnesses
at the time and that would have been
given on the best of
available information at the time the
public inquiry was heard in
in 2019 so
my instinct is that there was a thorough
analysis of this issue which led to
the expectation there'd be a surface
water drainage scheme
which uh which is set up i think in
conditions
uh 18 and subsequent conditions on on
that decision so
there was consideration given to it
councillor um and it was the best
consideration that could be given to an
outline application on the information
at that point in time and any applicant
can then
or any any developer can then rely on
this outline permission as having
established that principle and
as with all things in planning um we
must make the judgments we make on the
days that we make them
and uh hindsight is uh it's always 20 20
and
one uh one cannot be certain that
hindsight is necessarily going to
prove anything either way i think at
this point we have
uh we have a technical specification
and we have a design solution and
you know we we we have to expect that to
work
uh on the balance of probability rather
than beyond reasonable doubt thank you
yes thank you um i'm grateful to other
members for also
um looking closely at the um
this issue um i was firstly going to ask
but i think it's been answered now
as to where the um where this major leak
described on page 39 uh paragraph 8.4
where that was and i think we've heard
that it's it's the dark
the dark green patch beside the road
down there
um and then as i understand it the
inspector has only said
that the the drainage basin should be
in this area which was to be left
undeveloped
not just not more specifically than that
but
where's the where does it drain the base
and drain
out to where's the water course in this
area i'm not familiar with the area
sufficiently
just trying to unders really understand
this because i think
there is you know we are discussing a
risk here which we
ought to try and minimize
i can come and share uh councilman
matthew actually using infiltration so
it's not a discharge to a watercourse
oh right that that's that's that's you
so i understand thank you
okay thank you uh we have
which we'll move on um
all right next up um
uh we don't have a representative from
the parish council i understand
uh so we'll now uh move to the objector
stephen bates uh mr bates if you'd like
to turn your camera on
and your microphone on
good morning everybody can can you hear
me okay uh
yeah if if your camera hasn't come on
yet
but it probably does say it's a slow
so there we go okay welcome i think
we've called out yeah are we all good
we're all good so uh um robert will be
timing you have three minutes and if you
keep to the three minutes please over to
you
good morning again ladies and gentlemen
of the committee and since the
committee's unanimous decision to defer
this application last month
for the many reasons discussed we find
the application back before us
largely unchanged and i would at this
point like to thank belway holmes for
their consultations with myself in the
interim period
which have resulted in satisfactory
resolutions to both the buffer zone and
the plot one issues
however there appears to have been no
movement at all on the other two issues
which continue to gravely concern the
residents despite the many ideas and
compromises that we have offered them
with this in mind i come before you to
raise these serious concerns once more
one there will be a considerable
subsystem put in place
on the southern boundary of the site
this is directly above several low-lying
properties on old norwich road
whose properties already lie level with
the existing water table
even a fractional increase in this water
table will have a catastrophic result
for these residents we would like to
thank belway homes for their drainage
strategy non-technical
summary which i understand the committee
also has a copy of
unfortunately this does nothing to
alleviate the fears of these residents
as it clearly shows
all water from the site draining to the
rear of their properties and into the
wetland json
this will be protected simply by earth
mounds and we simply cannot comprehend
how this will not raise the water table
in this entire area or sphered
if bellway homes or the environment
agency are so confident in their
drainage designs
all we ask is that you provide
guarantees to the affected residents
that should their properties be flooded
in the future years they will be
properly compensated or protected
secondly we remain baffled by the
decision to build a roundabout
at the site access it still makes no
sense whatsoever to us either in terms
of road safety cost or pollution
as it stands the northbound entrance to
this roundabout will service just six
houses and two buses
an hour hardly the typical requirements
for a roundabout
there are numerous safety concerns we
have with such a junction such as cycle
safety
access to the adjacent livery and
existing residential driveways just a
few meters away from the roundabout to
name
but a few hopefully somebody from
suffolk highways is present i know they
are now
uh who can explain exactly why a
roundabout is so important to them as to
reject all other seemingly safer and
cheaper road layouts
in favor of the proposals we have before
us furthermore i would challenge suffolk
highways to commit to a reduction in the
speed limit on old norwich road
and an improved traffic enforcement
system at the basket as the current
system in place is laughable
and please do not insult our
intelligence by offering more signage as
a mitigation policy
as this clearly has not worked today and
will not in the future
finally the residents directly to the
side of the site entrance are quite
elderly and with this development
scheduled to last approximately five
years
that will likely be the rest of their
natural lives i would therefore ask the
committee to ensure that a sympathetic
management plan is created
and strictly enforced to ensure the
minimum noise impact possible to these
residents
thank you for your time today and i'd
welcome any questions
thank you very much for that um members
any questions
i've got a question that i'd like to uh
that'll ask the applicant based on
something i've just heard
uh so thank you for that uh council eben
um thank you chair um thank you for that
for your um your submission
um first just um could you tell me what
the speed limit is on norwich road
and secondly um you know recently we've
had a lot of rain
um what's um which obviously is becoming
more and more of a common occurrence
um can you tell me what flooding issues
that there
may or may not have been um in the last
month for neighbouring properties to
this site
thank you very much so is that question
directed at me
or it is indeed yes indeed okay thank
you yeah
the the it's currently national speed
limit um
uh to on old knowledge road at the
moment that starts it goes from 30 to
national speed limit
um pretty much um at the
ipswich boundary so as we switch from
its switch to mid-suffolk
there's a national speed limit which is
nonsensical really but there you go
um currently in terms of the flooding
issues
uh well the the deemed wetland area i
would say to you is currently
a roughly ankle deep as we speak and it
has been
really we have sent photographic
evidence of that in truth into the
planning officer
but it's ankle deep at the moment and it
has been probably for around about two
months now
um i i would actually just say because
there's been a lot of questions about
the suds and this old norwich road so
can i just add
there are dry ditches to the can i just
say i'm afraid you can
you can only ask answer questions that
are asked of you after the three minutes
okay does that answer the questions in
yes thank you very much and and chair my
ass
um yes sam harvey from highways
presumably if the roundabout treatment
goes in there will be the appropriate
speed limits um that need to happen with
a roundabout
yes thank you councillor even just i'd
like to confirm that the 30 mile high
speed limit the proposal is to extend it
to the bus gate
uh so that the the whole scheme is
within a 30 miler speed limit and the
site will be a 20 miler
thank you very much thank you uh
we have a question from council matheson
for you yeah it sounds if i need to ask
mr bates
uh what um what the um what the ditch
these dry ditches are doing um that are
um
you say they're dry ditches but there's
there's an anchor angled deep water at
the moment
i didn't quite understand the relation
there
okay uh thank you council app for asking
that question yes to the other side of
old norwich road there are existing dry
ditches in place
um evidently it seems to me that
what's happening is the water is being
stopped by old norwich road there is no
culvert underneath and therefore the
ditches that were and remain in place
but are now dry
just simply aren't being used because
the water can't drain away
um that that land is owned by ipswich
bower council as well so
it there is an opportunity i think to
actually resolve the problem here
so if i if i may check it sounds as if
perhaps there's something as simple as a
pipe under the road that's got blocked
which um mr skilton might like to um
ponder on
um after the meeting okay
your question counselor madison
we're in questions no it's been answered
now thank you okay
thank you councillor field
rather similar question and i mean i
must confess just looked at the ordnance
survey
profiles for the area on rs mapping
um clearly the land is lower to the um
eastern side here and i was about to ask
highways or jason um
you know what investigations have
under been undertaken to to check while
they said why this area is flooded
it may not have been an issue in the
past
but it uh clearly is now and the
knowledge road to my knowledge has been
there what 50 years
it's not exactly a new thing so we've
been out of time to get these
investigations done
have we considered anything
jason or sam do you want to come in on
that uh yeah
thank you councillor field he would up
to be up to the the applicant to look at
the the drainage under the old
um norwich road if there was a a culvert
that's been installed in there to drain
the land
it would be a mixture of different land
owners responsibility to make sure
that's maintained
um you know historically when these
roads were built there were
um coal was put underneath of them so it
could be that
um that there is a culvert there um it
hasn't been identified by by the
applicant as being a covenant present at
the moment
but if it is it likely to be the highway
authority's
responsibility to keep that culvert
managed and maintained in perpetuity
sam are we aware of one there at all
sorry chad no i i i'm not aware of that
um and afraid i can't find anything on
our system at the moment
okay thank you okay any other questions
uh for the objective cancer pass more
uh thanks matthew i know i'm a ward
member i can't vote but
one of the things i was going to say
just doing quite is it possible to put
this
as a under reserve matter and i think it
was mr bates said
some sort of guarantee to look at the
drainage because we could have a
protracted conversation
touring and throwing but that to me
would summarize
all the issues that have been quite
rightly being raised and that does need
to reassure
the residents i i've got that on my list
to ask the applicant when the applicant
comes forward okay
thank you and then we can take it from
there perfect
thank you okay thank you very much uh
for joining us today
thank you actually i should go now
thank you um okay we don't have a
supporter
uh so i'll now ask the agent laura
dudley smith to speak
and i understand that sarah cornwell and
joel war are also here to answer
questions so
uh if i could ask the agent to turn your
camera on please
can you hear me okay yeah we can and
welcome and again if you could keep to
three minutes please over to you
thank you good morning members thank you
for allowing us to present to you again
this morning on behalf of fairway
since you last considered this
application on the 20th of january
belway homes have been working with
their project team
as well as local residents and the
parish council to address the eight
issues raised as reasons for the
referral and can therefore now provide
the following update
all instances of triple parking have
been removed apart from one down a
private drive and near visitor parking
where it was
unavoidable without a significant
redesign of the scheme
we have liaised further with neighboring
residents to provide reassurances that
the landscape buffer area to the rear of
existing dwellings along old norwich
road will be one single area and
appropriately secured and managed
again through further consultation with
neighbours plot one has been revised to
move the two-story dwelling
9.7 metres from the rear boundary of the
old filling station
instead of 3.5 a single story double
garage provides the separation
and the roof pitch of this has been
reduced as requested by and in agreement
with the neighbours
beltway homes cannot be expected to take
forward an access proposal that cannot
be supported by the highways adopting
authority suffolk county council
as such we have proposed further
improvements to the roundabout
arrangement to ensure a level of safety
for all users including cyclists that
goes beyond that already considered
acceptable by suffolk county and agreed
these with their officers
this includes additional road marking
improvements to the existing cycle lanes
a reduced speed limit all the way up to
the bus state
and a segregated roundabout bypass
recycling cyclist traveling southbound
there will be no chimneys constructed
anywhere on the scheme
beltway shall be maintaining their use
of gas boilers to spoilers whilst there
is no policy
or building regulations to require
otherwise belway do however offer
exemplary sustainability credentials in
other ways
through their fabric first approach to
construction for example this means that
the priority
is to reduce energy usage in the first
place through means such as building
orientation
air tightness glazing and insulation
railways strive to retrieve 10
over building regulations energy
efficiency requirements
and we'll be providing electric vehicle
charging connections for all residents
a full sustainability strategy for the
scheme has also now been submitted
additional information has been provided
to demonstrate how opportunities to
connect to the existing public rights of
way along the southern boundary of the
site
will provide enhanced pedestrian
connectivity and to link to the new
internal network of footpaths across the
public open space the drainage strategy
has been informed by the existing site
conditions and topography and has been
approved by suffolk county council as
the lead local flood authority
further discussions with county officers
have taken place and additional
information has again been provided to
all to clarify how the proposed system
will operate
an underground pipe network combined
with landscaping buns around existing
dwellings will ensure a betterment to
existing surface water conditions
the basin will be managed in accordance
with the maintenance and management
scheme agreed with suffolk county and
mid-suffolk planning officers
we trust that this clarification is
helpful for your further consideration
of this scheme
and allows for a favorable determination
and
as you said i'm happy to take any
questions and also supported by um
sarah cornwell of bellway homes and joel
our um site engineer
thank you thank you thanks very much uh
councillor mayor you're first off
thank you um laura thanks uh
for your statement as i understand it a
gas combi boiler is significantly
smaller than
um an air source heat pump and
associated uh
cylinders given the small size of some
of the
properties you intend to put on this is
the size of the heating system
um being part of the considerations by
berway homes in selecting the gas
economy boiler
i think it's um it's it's a factor
um but that's combined with a number of
factors so at the moment obviously
there's
um we've had uh in the sustainability
strategy um
recently submitted so everyone can refer
to that if needed and then they
undertake an appraisal of the use of air
source heat pumps um
and kind of weigh up the pros and cons
obviously there are um
pros to them as systems at the moment
there still remains cons where
it um ultimately they're not um
sort of by and fairway have an overall
energy strategy as you refer to in terms
of how they work their their homes and
in terms of the efficiency fabric bursts
and things like that
and so to then to introduce the air
source heat pumps into that will require
a significant rehaul
of that strategy and for the homes and
the house type things
will be designed differently to
accommodate those uses so
um it's certainly you know it will be
something that will have to consider
in the future but at the moment until um
the you know until it's enforced through
planning policies and building
regulation requirements it's a
um it's a significant requirement for
the bear way to take on
yeah i mean it's interesting um
you you talk about designing the
buildings my concern is that uh
you put in a combi boiler which is nice
and small and compact
and then leave the residents to pick up
the cost of rebuilding the
the the properties to accommodate a
heating system in the future now that
may well be
um compliant with existing policy but
it's it's hugely disappointing
that the developers that are leaving um
the
their future residence to pick up the
cost of a design
specification that could be done now we
could design that in now and make those
buildings um
capable of going on for many years to
come so
whilst i doubt whether we have any um
ability to enforce heat pumps it is
hugely disappointing that they're not
being designed in at this time
thanks
thanks uh just just to be clear we are
at this point just asking questions
um and we get into bait shortly on the
merits uh councillor field
just to repeat my question i guess i
think it may have been answered more or
less but the
the point was that fabric first is
obviously something which one
appreciates is a a good direction of
travel
but i my assumption is that doesn't
actually preclude you
putting in sustainable means of heating
i.e probably air sourced
but possibly ground-sourced heat pumps
just like that confirmed the second
point perhaps is
there are clearly government grants at
the moment that
provide a continuous payment for people
using sustainable
heating methods is that available to
people
on new
those people bui get a payment from the
government
every year as i would have done had i
upgraded my house
or is that something that's not
available to new residents
thank you
um yeah i can come back on those i think
um no you're right
obviously the use of fabric burst
doesn't um
preclude the use of heat pumps um solely
it's simply
i suppose that um you know the way
berway have operated today is that
um that's their that's the priority
because that you know using the use of
fabric first initiatives such as
insulation
placing uh many over building
efficiencies
um is the starting point that
sets the baseline regardless then of how
the energy is is sourced
um beyond that and what's used so that
their
priority is to reduce the amount of
energy used um
before you then consider where that
energy comes from
um in terms of the
um grants um you know probably wouldn't
be the best place to advise in terms of
how
the specific you know specific specifics
of how those grants
will operate do operate um or will in
the future
and i suppose i would just add though
that in addition
that we um our sustainability advisors
are aware of the intentions to be
providing
grants in the future for any conversions
of
technologies or things like that as well
and that would of course
obviously apply to these residents
amongst all others
um and so i think in terms of the the
queries raised previously on the
the you know the requirement for
residents to
take those costs themselves um it would
be that they would be no more
unreasonable to anyone else with an
existing gas boiler
thank you okay councillor matheson uh
sorry councillor mayor did you want
council matheson right
thank you yes uh previous councillors
have covered a good deal of the ground
and really i'm just left wondering um
why the agent thinks that other
developed
mass housing developers are coming to us
with with air source heat pumps as
standard
um but belleway still and i have read
your
uh aes um consultants report in detail
carefully
um to just try and understand what the
argument was and
um really why why are others doing air
source and why are you still going for
gas
and so that's you know from from my
position as agent i can only
simply advise that that is the um that's
the chosen strategy of beltway homes at
the moment is
um you know it's appraised in terms of
um you know across all areas
and that's um that's been the decision
they they make ultimately
um we do have um sarah on the call from
below home specifically if there's
anything else she has to add on that
um if if she wants
is there anything you want to add or i
was enough
not getting a hand up yeah hi sarah
hi i'm sorry um yeah i suppose just to
add
that um it is something that we're
looking at uh it's something because
as a group bill we're looking at um as
you know
it's not building regulations at the
moment we are trying to get ahead of the
game but it's something that um
it needs a lot of investigation it means
a real redesign of
the internal spec a lot of the houses so
it's not something that we can just on a
whim
do it takes a lot of technology um and
uh we're still at the early stages of
that so in a couple years time i'm sure
we'll be there but
at this stage we just aren't there with
the technology unfortunately
in the design of our house building uh
program
right i'm sure we'll just return to that
in this debate thank you chair
thank you councillor eben
um thank you chair sorry to label the
point but the the
sustainability report says
their own report heat pumps are a
relatively mature
technology so
i just you know can you confirm you know
one that you know can it be re-looked at
is the question to that and secondly you
did mention
about all the other aspects of
sustainability including orientation can
you
explain which houses are planned out
according to the orientation of the
site in terms of solar gain thank you
very much
um okay so yes the technologies
may be mature but they're not mature in
terms of well we haven't been
using them on a side-by-side basis so
there have been the odd schemes we've
used them um i think we used it at
our barking scheme um and there was a
lot of problems with it and we've
actually taken it out now
is my understanding so it's not
something that we can generally just
just retrofit our properties to do
um it will take us a while to get to the
technology
within our bill program um
what was the other question sorry um
orientation thank you um
i couldn't be specific to be honest with
you it's something that the architect
will look at
as his redesign in the buildings and and
the layout obviously we had to fit in
with the uh
the outline planning permission and the
um parameters plan that was set out
there so
the housing has to be in a certain uh
position in terms of where the roads are
as well
um but i couldn't tell you on what what
plot my plot basis and unfortunately
thank you very much philip you want to
come in
thank you chairman yes if i may yes just
just to go back over that point
and i fully understand and and i
recognize where members are coming from
with this question of
uh uh the interest in heating
it is important to remember this is a
reserve matters application
the principle of this development is set
reserve matters include access
appearance landscaping layout and scale
they do not on the face of it include
the internal arrangements for heating
the buildings that would have been a
thing which
were it to be relevant to a planning
matter should have probably been covered
at the outline stage so i think we
have to be careful in handling how we
approach that
and for similar reasons clearly
there are a number of conditions on the
outline permission and we are discussing
suds
and that clearly relates to landscaping
and perhaps to some degree to layout
but there are other conditions which
manage and govern that so we do have to
respect the fact that
any developer whoever they may be is
entitled to rely on the existence
existence of an outline permission but
we don't have the luxury of revisiting
that thank you jim
um i guess my question is we've heard
the concerns of the neighbours around
the suds
and the location and we've we've heard
from
the floods team wyatt's in that location
it does seem that is probably the best
location
but what sort of comfort can we give the
residents who are just behind just in
front of that
location in terms of we often hear one
in a hundred years and then
a year later we hear that actually we've
just had the flooding in one in a
hundred years or
uh you know one in a biblical event and
suddenly we're told well that
wasn't expected but it was a biblical
event and it seems to be happening more
and more
so i'm just wondering the subs system is
going to have to be maintained
it's going to have to be operated how
can we put something in place
to give the residents that confidence
those particular residents located right
in front of it
so i think as you suggest um it feels to
me as the best
the best avenue for that is through the
um the management and maintenance
schemes
that are proposed um so there's um
in terms of the specifics for the sub
space and there's
we have been required under the
conditions for the application we have
to provide details for
subs the management and maintenance of
the assets in particular
um but also the south basin as a
landscaping feature falls under the
landscape management
plan as well um so that's the same
management plan that
we've referred to in terms of the
management of the landscape buffer area
for example which includes
um checks of i think at least um
uh every fortnight across the site um
general
um you know rubbish clearance things
like that and obviously the nature of
them
going outside and undertaking that
maintenance um all
existing residents and we've we've
suggested that um
well all new residents and we've
suggested existing residents that they
could also have them would obviously be
provided with the details of
that management company um and the
appropriate contacts in that regard
and also of course the subspace in
itself will um
be kind of an adopted asset of suffolk
county council registered registered on
their system as well so there is a kind
of secondary
um sort of inquiry or all kind of
procedure is there yeah i mean the
problem is that would be after the event
yeah um uh i mean i don't even know if
this is within planning so philip
or or brad you have told me if i'm going
way off the mark here
but you know you can get a one-off
indemnity insurance that someone takes
out over the lifetime of something
uh to prevent something happening i mean
they're not hugely expensive but you
have a one
a once-off indemnity policy you buy to
protect those houses which is just
sits there in case anything were to
happen in the future
um i mean you know my view is those
residents need some sort of comfort but
i don't know if that's within
planning if it's even permissible but
philip you can you'll tell me if i've
gone way off
track here uh heaven forbid german
heaven forbid
um it it's it's usually a matter of
private law if i'm really honest
um and i know that's a very unwelcome
kind of answer i think
the important point is that we
make sure that the uh that the surface
water management plan
as far as reasonably possible to the
standards we'd expect across the county
you know does this in a way which we
would expect for our own properties as
anybody else's i guess
um i don't think we can require an
indemnity i don't think that's a
reasonable step for a planning authority
to take i fully understand and you can
obtain them i'm sure
for these things but that's a civil
matter and i wouldn't suggest we have
the opportunity to do that what we do
have is the opportunity to sign off on a
reasonable surface water management plan
and that's a point where the planning
authority will be guided by the advice
and experience in other cases of the
flood authority chairman
it's come back then so so five years
down the road
phillip uh when this or ten years down
the road when this is built and the
the houses have been there five or ten
years uh you know how
how can we know that the management will
be ongoing to protect the residents that
are already there because often with
these things
things do slip a bit over time and
that's my worry in the first
you know over time the management it
relaxes a bit
you know things are established eyes
taken off the ball
so it's that long-term confidence for
those residences i think
is what i'm after rather than i'm sure
in the early years everything
will work but it's the long-term comfort
uh well chairman i mean i'd i'd probably
look to
a little uh input from jason and uh on
the flood authority side of this
i understand what you're saying and it's
not unusual for
for some uh for some matters to become
less important but clearly flooding is a
long-term interest for the flood
authority
um the county as as flood authority has
a long-term commitment to the county to
manage surface water and flooding
incidents
and we are as planning authority
involved in discussion with them and
with others about experience across the
county so
and a long-term management plan which is
effectively for the lifetime of the
dwellings is what's essential here
because the
surface water issues will arise for that
duration so
this isn't this isn't a five-year
landscaping plan where if people don't
plant the plants or some of them die we
just say oh well that happened you know
this is
drainage surface water drainage and you
know the ability to manage
uh unexpected events is a very real and
a very challenging
um construction detail which needs to be
dealt with here and now because
and we have one opportunity to get this
right and the inspector
provided that in a surface water
management plan condition
to ensure that's in a surface water in
stormwater is
is managed he didn't set a time limit on
that he didn't say that was for five
years or ten years that's
a surface water management plan and from
my perspective that's a
the important point i'd look at in
looking at that condition detail is
that long-term commitment and you know
if these houses have to be for a
thousand years then these
this this arrangement has to work for a
thousand years what we can't do
we can't predict the climate and we have
to work on the best information we have
today
um so i think i'll leave it there for
the time being and i don't know if jason
wants to add anything about that
yeah i will come in and so with regard
to the management and maintenance
um the applicant has put forward
management and maintenance plans as part
of the discharge of condition
application
um and essentially will be done in
accordance with uh
national um guidance which is the the
the what we look at
um ideally if um a lot of the
legislation as part of the flood and war
management act had actually been enacted
um suffolk county council has the local
leader flood authority
would have been actually a subs adoption
body and
these types of assets would have been
taken on by ourselves
however the government at the time
decided not to enact that part of the
flood and water management act
so we i'm afraid are left with um
different um avenues for management and
maintenance with regard to who does it
um it could have been put up for
adoption to angling water but because of
the application
was of an age before the utility
companies took on
surface water drainage with regards to
subs features that's not an option
the other option would be that the
district council took it on as part of
public open space
beyond the understanding that mid
suffolk don't wish to take on
additional public open space which
utilizes suds features
so the third and final option i'm afraid
is it sits with a private management
firm
which would either be wholly owned by
bellway or could actually be arranged so
that
all the um owners of the properties
are sort of joint owners that's only the
only options are
available i'm afraid okay thank you
tim thanks matthew i'm really just
backing up what was saying but surely it
can't be beyond the wit of man
if it is a condition of the planning um
permission and i know these are reserved
matters to have an effective management
plan for the water well there has to be
a mechanism to make sure it's enforced
because like you said matthew the worry
is
go down 10 15 years these things do have
a habit of
just not being applied so maybe there is
a way to do it and another suggestion
and i don't want to get too technical
about this but perhaps with the sill
payments there is a way forward could we
could i suggest to the committees as i
can't vote on this
that is part of the if commission is
given well can i suggest you add that
you comment on that when we get to your
your your speech absolutely suggest that
i'll be happy to do that
thank you uh uh
phillip israel you want to come back in
no i'll i'll come back later
yes okay any other questions for the
applicant at the stage
no okay thank you thank you very much
for joining us and thank you for
answering the questions
okay um my notes
uh i'll now go on to the ward members we
have two ward members who
uh able to speak here counselor tim
passmont councillor
john whitehead um over to you in
whichever order you want to go
i think john's going to do do do this
first and then i'll come in afterwards
if that's right
cancer white head over to thank you
good morning members i'd like to start
by first thanking you for your decision
on the 20th of january where you asked
the applicant to take some more time
and reconsider various aspects of their
application
i agreed with the conclusions you
reached at that meeting
there is no doubt that belleway have
always sought to consult and liaise with
the local residents on this application
and i commend them for doing so since
the last committee meeting the parish
council myself also met virtually with
bellway and the representative
representatives
we have had some useful discussions and
interchange of views
there are some great improvements in
their revised plans although i myself
did not raise the issue of triple
parking
the committee were correct to do so and
i'm pleased that this is being resolved
for all bar one plot
when excellent revision relates to the
change that below have made to plot one
following both my representations and
those of misdebates on behalf of his
elderly parents
changes are almost certainly needed and
this new configuration which
includes transposing the house in the
garage and plot one
and also reducing elevation of that
garage roof is much appreciated
it is a great improvement when the
parish council and i recently had a
virtual meeting with belleway
a considerable portion of the meeting
focused on the roundabout
it's quite clear that bellway's hands
are tied by the requirements set out by
the highways authority
when it comes to layout of the entrance
to the estate
it would define logic for belway to
submit a plan for this entrance
that result in the estate road not
becoming adoptable
as a public road so the applicant the
parish council
and myself as ward member would prefer a
different configuration
but it seems we must refer to the
highways experts and their firm belief
that this mini roundabout
is the correct solution belway have
worked within those constraints
and have made improvements to the
cycling configuration
there remains real concern about current
access by all vehicles that close
section of the old norwich road
which by law should be buses only
i do understand this issue predates
belway's involvement this area
and it also falls outside and in a red
line boundary
but something does need to be done to
improve the tank trap
and its cctv and to discourage illegal
use of this closed road some mechanism
needs to be found
so that as i said at the last committee
meeting money from this new development
must go towards beefing up the barriers
and are monitoring the illegal road use
maybe using anpr
technology rather than someone just
watching a screen 24
7. it also remains clear in my mind that
many new residents for children
attending the schools in clayton
will be tempted to use this an
authorized route for much easier access
to these facilities
i share local residents views that more
could be done regarding the local
flooding
and water runoff from the site i can
understand that the burns created around
the suds basin
should help but clearly the biggest
issue seems to be that the old norwich
road
is a barrier that prevents the escape
for the water from the wetlands part of
the site
to the dry culverts on the east side of
the road
the electricity pylons and cables on the
site clearly prevent any building in
this area
and maybe i'm being over cynical but i
do wonder whether beltway might have
found a better drainage solution
had they been able to use this part of
the site for building
whilst the work is being undertaken on
the old norwich road with the creation
of the new
access to the site it would certainly
help existing affected local residents
if improved drainage could be arranged
under the road
to remove this water buildup
finally can i rethreat mr bates request
that a sympathetic management plan
which can be strictly enforced is
created to mitigate the effect on near
neighbours
of the lengthy construction period of
this large site
i would request committee members give
due consideration to the matters
i've raised as you debate the revised
submission before you this morning thank
you very much
thank you and everest council um thank
you
matthew i i won't repeat what term
councillor whitehead has
already said but just a couple of other
points to add add to this
um regarding the bus gate i do think
that's absolutely fundamental we need to
make sure
that there is a proper system of
enforcement there john suggested ampr
and just so members do realize the
police do have activity down there and i
think it was last week or the week
before they did issue four penalty
tickets
but technology would be a solution could
i suggest that perhaps
some of the um seal money that will be
accrued from the development could be
used to deal with that
um because i think that would be very
very helpful to do that
and also as i hinted earlier in my
question regarding
a guarantee about flooding i do think we
need to do everything possible
to try and find that and again i don't
know whether this is permitted or not
but i would suggest there'll be a fairly
sizable seal payment
maybe that would help address the
concern of those residents who might be
vulnerable to flooding because we have
to
look ahead for the extremes that we do
get and i absolutely take the point
once in a hundred years well those of us
will remember the great storm of 1987
which is once in every 250 years
and we had another serious scale i think
it was about seven or eight years
afterwards but
i'm just making the point on that and
the only other comment i would make
um i absolutely agree with what to the
general the
general conversation of the committee
members has been regarding
heating systems it is a pity that we are
not looking at these other technologies
air force
heat pumps and ground force heat pumps
yes there are some grants and supports
available
i think an enlightened approach to this
would be that at least some of them
perhaps could be included
having said all that uh i too would like
to thank belway holmes and for the
engagement that they've done
they have moved very quickly which is
unusual so a couple of brownie points
for that
to address the concerns and i think
overall they have done done a good job
to do that and
it would be good if all developers had
that same positive approach in my view
to address the concerns
thank you chairman very much very much
do we have any questions for the ward
members
no okay uh yes you've got one hand's
gone up
well yes councillor mansell yeah
my question is maybe not for the ward
members to answer but it's something
that was raised by councillor passmore
um that i would like some clarification
on um he mentioned
um the possibility of using sell payment
to
i think his terms would beef up the um
bus
gate or whatever it was called um and
for drainage issues and can i just have
some clarification that seal payments
are the sort of the district police
still payments
are actually allowed to be used for such
things as that because do they come
under the
auspices of highways which aren't
covered by seal
phillip isbell can you come in on that
please
uh i thank you chairman yes i think
council manslaughter has the distinct
advantage of a question which i don't
have an immediate answer to i think
my recollection is that highway matters
are section 106
uh related um public transport related
matters are part of the infrastructure
of
uh cell and my instinct is that
um and having had a long conversation
about bus stops as part of this
conversation and bus stops almost
certainly are a sill matter we've
established that
my instinct is if you're managing a
route such that buses are the vehicles
allowed to use it
that probably does sit within cell can i
take that question away for a little bit
and think further on it but at the
moment my instinct
is that a seal bid for that is uh within
the realms of
of the possible uh uh if you're looking
to establish an ampr
system there um i don't think it's
it's necessarily a section 106 matter it
is also a matter that's not necessarily
related to this development or driven by
this development so it probably wouldn't
be something that you would
i would naturally recommend to you as a
section 106 obligation but if i can just
reflect further on that chairman that's
that's my thoughts at the moment and the
drainage
what about drainage are they still
covered or not
uh i will also need to think on that one
because i can't immediately recall the
uh the
the terms of the the sill uh
contribution i suspect it may well be
but i will need to check that so leave
that with me please
okay thank you thank you
okay any other questions for the ward
members
no okay members well we've had all the
information put before us
um do philip are you happy we can oh uh
sarah councilman
are you happy we continue uh into the
debate then we just hear from philip
at some point yes i'm sure it will be
mentioned in debate
as well anyway but yes um if you can if
you can beaver away in the background
that's fine
that's fine okay great so we'll go into
debate now so uh members it's over to
you
uh to discuss we've had all the
information put before us into a reach
conclusion
uh councillor muller you were first yes
thank you chair i've listened with great
interest
about the discussion on the heat pumps
etcetera but um i would draw members
attention to
one of the conclusions on page 153
regarding the
air source heat pump system apparently
air air source heat pumps are
technically feasible for the buildings
in this scheme
however the potential increase in carbon
dioxide emissions associated with their
use
in comparison to a gas baseline under
current regulations means they are not
considered a preferred
low carbon technology at this stage
i thought that's quite an interesting
point and with regards to the
the ground source heat pumps the
conclusion
on that is that uh ground source heat
pumps or i'll keep losing on my page
hang on i'm just trying to get it back
again
uh here we go not quite um
so i'm just trying to scroll it up
yeah um
apologies i'll have to go on on the
papers hang on
it's uh with regards to the ground
source
heat pumps the argument
is and i quote ground source heat pumps
are considered technically feasible for
buildings in this scheme
however the cost and difficulty
associated with vertical boreholes
at this site means that they are not
considered a viable or preferred
low-carbon technology
at this stage i think that's really
quite an important point here
and that was the only point i was going
to make on that but i do also agree with
the comments made about the suds
and whether some of the culverts are
blocked underneath the old norwich road
then perhaps that does need to look look
into quite urgently
thank you chair thank you
carson matheson's asked if we can have a
uh a comfort break and we do normally
have a comfort break after 90 minutes
and
my apologies we have gone just over 90
minutes 100 minutes
yeah i know my apologies i hadn't kept
my eye on that so i'm very happy to have
a quick 10 minute break
uh can we please just make sure we have
no discussion about the application
and we'll start again at 20 past 11.
thanks welcome back everyone we'll just
do a quick roll call just to check
uh we're all present and we can continue
the debate
rob over to you please thank you jim so
if members could just inform me that
they are present
so councillor richard mayer
president we're all here chair lovely
thanks very much
okay so we've uh just had we've started
the debate
and we now move on to councillor field
i'm sorry before we do that um philip
isbell's just uh
been through the points that were raised
and we can just come and hear those
before we continue
philip over to first yeah thank you
thank you chairman yes
uh councilman asked two questions one
was about uh the potential to use
sale in relation to the bus gate uh
infrastructure
question and in relation to uh the
drainage matter uh certainly in relation
to the bus gate i mean i'm fairly
comfortable that
there's there's potential to use that in
relation to policing at the bus gate it
seems to me to
fit within potentially both improvements
in public transport and transport
infrastructure points which are
captured under cs6 of your core strategy
are less comfortable around the surface
water point
chairman because i don't see quite how
that fits at this point in time with
anything that's listed as
an item of infrastructure utility
provision is
is included but at the moment i'm not
convinced that that's what this is so if
i can leave it there
thank you for that councillor field
thank you i think um
broadly i'm in favour of development
it is necessary to build houses to meet
various commitments particularly those
to
young people within the area and
as the report points out this
development is in the ipswich fringe
i think it's mid-switch fringe not baber
as the report states but nevertheless
it's ipswich fringe and therefore there
is a presumption that it's a
place where there is good access uh by
public transport uh good access in a
variety of ways
it's even within walking distance of
much of the town and it's
employment and there are good employment
opportunities
so my feeling is that is reasonable
but there are a set of issues that we
must make sure
highways resolve particularly highways
perhaps others as well
the cycling thing
improvements to the roundabout are
welcome it would be good if that was a
completed
set of conditions so people could
totally see what the issues are
in that area and the safety problems
have been addressed
uh it's a long time since i rode 10
miles to work every day but
once quite aware that cycling is more
hazardous than driving your car
we need to do what we can to minimize
the hazard
on the issue of the bus gates it's
probably incorrect
for me to state that as the county
councillor
i offered highways the money to put in
an apnr camera
when sandra gage was the highways
engineer for the area
so it's not been done for a long time we
really need
something to do to do something to
ensure that
the facility is used legally there's a
simple method
of enforcing that um clearly the sort of
cameras that one uses to
police entry to waste sites are not
expensive
could be applied and if they can be
required
to be funded through sil that would be
marvelous
on the issue of drainage i think it's a
similar issue that there is clearly a
long-term problem there
long-term probably means a 50-year
problem with
increased number of houses it needs to
addressing
and clearly the roundabout construction
is going to disturb
the surface of the old norwich road
pretty substantially
so there would seem to be an opportunity
to make improvements
it may just be that culverts under the
road
drones under the road of blocked that
was done
that occurred on more than one road in
this particular area so it's quite
possible that that is
that it's a simple problem to resolve if
not
i think highways need to attack that
issue
um i'll continue slightly on that front
solar panels um one understands that
there are cost to each development and
that now there is no feed-in tariff the
yield from them the monetary yield is
not dramatic
although there is obviously a yield in
useful electricity into the grid
it is a concern and a regret that we
can't persuade
builders to put such things on the roof
of new houses
uh part of the cost of that is we're
about to lose some 240 acres of prime
farmland in the area to provide the
panels
in a different location but one
recognises the arguments
so i think um
that's my line of our reasoning um i say
i'm broadly in favor i will listen
obviously to the rest of the debate
and see if there's anything persuades me
otherwise
thank you thank you thank you very much
uh councilli ben
you're next
thank you very much chair um i
appreciate that
the consultation that's taken place
between belleway um and
residents and that they have made
changes to this application
but i also understand um residents
concerns um
the immediate residents especially in
relation to flooding i think one of the
things that we have to do
is we have to protect the interests of
um
current and future residents in the
decisions that we make
one of those areas is in with regards to
sustainability
um there is a sustainability strategy
and sorry sustainability and energy
strategy noted in the conditions
but it's disappointing that a developer
is
looking just to meet the minimum and not
actually look to
really protect the resident's future
needs
and it would be a shame more than shame
if future residents were then to put you
know pv
on the roofs of their homes or take out
gas boilers and put in whatever um
source of heat
is is needed and i think it
is just unfortunate that while fabric
first
is a um a principle that leads to
well-insulated
homes um i do think in this day and age
we are well beyond
just saying let's just insulate the
homes we really need to to push further
and
i'm disappointed that the developer
hasn't got a more forward thinking view
on that i'm particularly thinking for
the future
um for the residents on this site
um the other issue um particularly and
just sorry just on that sustainable
strategy i don't know if in the
conditions
we can actually ask for something extra
or how that can be beefed up in any way
um the other big issue to me seems to be
about flooding
and including flooding off-site um and
again you know what is the long-term
plan
can something be done between about this
sort of barrier as it were that is the
norwich road
um with culverts or or however can that
be
part of the um conditions again with
regards to
um the the drainage and suds features
um and i do think we really need to give
confidence
to local residents that this development
isn't going to
impact on them in that way and that in a
few years time we'll be getting
complaints to councils saying our houses
are
houses are flooding because of this
development right so we really need to
do what we can
can i just ask philip can we do any sort
of informative note
around the issue of the flooding under
the road
and and the points are being raised is
there anything that we can do to
to flag up our concerns so that they are
looked at
uh it's not uncommon chairman for the
committee to
uh where you have matters like this uh
traffic regulation orders sometimes for
instance
to send a parallel instruction to
officers to
uh follow that question up and as i said
you've got a series of conditions here
on the outline planning permission which
do require
uh the um the surface order management
issue to be looked at
uh and and that's already under
consideration so i'm not going to speak
further about that but yeah it's
perfectly possible for committee to send
a parallel instruction never mind
deciding
so so just i'm just throwing it out
there could we put a uh
uh informative note along the lines of
the uh
along the lines of um making sure that
the residents the existing residents are
absolutely um you know the the further
work is done
to ensure the safety of the existing
premises
and the issue of the flooding
along the old norris road to make sure
that you know
we want to see some action there not
just left to to continue
i mean how can we phrase that because
you're hearing the message i mean
everyone's saying the same thing they're
two big issues i mean the sustainability
issue is a different issue
and we've we've covered why we can't
enforce uh ground source or airs or seat
pumps but
but on those two points what can we do
uh so chairman you can you can add an
informative that
you would expect the planning authority
and the flood authority
to have uh undertaken reasonable
investigation
of the local residents concerns
regarding surface water drainage issues
and uh any any culverts or drains under
the road
as uh as part of their review of
the uh surface water drainage planning
conditions that are attached to the
outline so you can send that as
i mean it's effectively an instruction
to officers if you can leave the the
thinking around some wording on that
chairman just so that
uh we can formalize it in a in a way
that is uh
understandable to all that money i mean
i'm just throwing it out there may not
be the wish of the committee but just
just so that we know what we can and
can't do
i if i give it some if i give it some
thought chairman um and
you know that's that's that's certainly
something that committee can't do
thank you council even did you want to
add anything else um thank you chair yes
well i i just wanted to you know
reiterate if i may that those
two particular issues and and i think we
you know as i said we do need to protect
the interests of both current and future
residents and um i would like to have
seen more movement from
um belway on the sustainability issues
um as we have seen from other developers
and and i do hope that um
you know we can put something in the
conditions if other if members are
wanted to approve but i'll wait to hear
what my other colleagues say thank you
very much chair thank you
uh councilman councillor mayor
uh thank you chair um i'll try not to uh
cover stuff that's already been
mentioned by my fellow councillors
um but but here we are um trying to
determine a reserve matters application
uh
for the out to follow on from the
outline permission which
was granted by appeal so we're not
disputing that there are going to be
some houses on this land
um we we ne we need to make sure that
the houses that are built on this
particular plot of land
are uh suitable and and the optimum
layout optimum design all the rest of it
uh for this particular location
and as yet i am to be convinced that we
do have
the optimum solution to put in houses on
this particular plot of land
whilst i agree that it's really pleasing
that beltway has
has worked with the parish council and
the planning officers and the
highways department to address some of
the issues that we raised last month
um i won't go on about the um gas
fired boilers because others have
already mentioned that but
i i would just like to query something
that that
philip isbell did mention saying that
that we weren't in a position to
insist on this because it was part of
the outline now
to my mind well however you're going to
heat your house
to me is part an integral part of the
design of the house and i thought design
was a reserve matter but maybe i'm wrong
um
uh however my my biggest bug bear
about this whole hoo-ha is the
roundabout
and i completely agree with the
residents comments that
why on earth suffolk highways proposing
a roundabout here
when the vast majority of traffic coming
along old norwich road
will be going to this new development um
straight on
is a dead end for cars uh it's a bus
lane and it's a cycle lane it's part of
the national cycle network
and we all know and we all agree and and
thank you very much for suffolk county
highways offices to be present today
uh to answer my queries on this um but
we still don't seem to have the final
answer for the layout of the roundabout
um to make sure that it's suitable for
cyclists
now we all know and i'm glad it's really
appreciated that
for a cyclist who wants to effectively
turn right to roundabout they should hog
the right-hand lane
if you are a novice cyclist a young
child cycling to school
you are probably not going to have the
assertiveness or the confidence
to hog the road when there's a bus
snorting up behind you
and a load of traffic uh slewing around
to the left of a roundabout
uh and it is going to deter um people
from using
what is essentially meant to be part of
our national cycle network
there will be children going from
whitten to school in claydon
um and and i do not think that a
roundabout
is the best option for this particular
location
had this road not been part of a
national cycle network i probably
wouldn't be arguing so much about it
um so i i just don't think that
the the access arrangements uh quite
fit the bill um for this particular
location
so i i'm uh at the moment that that is
my sticking point
and for that reason at the moment i'm
not prepared to support this application
however i'm not sure that my views are
shared by the rest of this committee
um and uh in follow-up to my question
about the use of sill payments to
enhance the um security or whatever you
want to call it
of the bus gate um uh thanks very much
uh for the confirmation that this is
something that seal money can be used
for
um again because this isn't isn't
demanded
as as a as a you know from this
development
is that something that we have to put in
as informative that it needs to be
looked into
and and who would actually be applying
for the sale money
to do this work uh who is responsible
for maintaining the integrity of a bus
only lane
uh because as i my understanding still
is somebody has to apply for the money
and then uh you know carry out the work
uh
you know it's presumably it's not us as
the district council's um
responsibility um is it the county
council
or who you know whose responsibility is
it to
to make that bid for still money and get
that work done
okay that's ours but he can probably
answer that question for you
thank you chairman um so as a piece of
of infrastructure associated with the
highway i would expect the county
highway authority to lead on that
i understand from my colleague
christine thurlow that this work would
need to be identified in the district's
infrastructure funding statement but i
think that it will be for the
county to lead on the provision of that
as an item of infrastructure and set
specifications for it so that's where
that would start chairman you don't
particularly need to do anything in this
committee and uh
one can send a a message as a further
point of an informative around this as a
request
that that be explored but ultimately it
rests with others to
to to make the formal request for sale
funding as i understand it thank you
okay councillor mayor thank you
thanks chair um not wishing to repeat
what
other councils said but i think belway
should be applauded for
the um the effort they've made to
address the issues
that we highlighted and indeed to engage
with the local residents so
that's excellent um the roundabout um
yeah i think that's down to highways
they're the authority they've got to
make the decision
um though i think council mansell makes
very good points
heating hugely disappointing but
actually outside our remit
but i thought it was telling when the um
railways representative said they didn't
want to redesign the internal spec of
the houses
so they're quite happy to pass that cost
on to the residents which is
hugely disappointing because we know
that things like
heat source pumps will be used in the
future
my big issue is is around the suds and
drainage mr isabel
made the point that we should consider
is the um the suds
solution reasonable well i don't think
we can say it's reasonable we have a
known drainage problem on this side that
hasn't been addressed
and we've superimposed a sud system on
top of that
how can we be sure that they won't
interact what what is going to be the
net effect
so i don't think it is reasonable to
ignore a known drainage issue
and just superimpose the subsystem on
top
and and part of me just wishes people
could be more creative
here we have an area that is almost
a wetlands in itself can we not combine
the two
thereby removing the threat to the
houses
and creating a more um
uh a wildlife area that would add huge
benefit
um so i don't think enough works been
done around the suds
and uh drainage in its in its entirety
it needs to be looked at um as one
package
and on that basis unless we can put in
some very
strong conditions i'm not sure i can
support this application as it stands
thank you thank you
um counselor matheson
yes uh again shalt re repeat lots of
things i i must say
i'm uh agreeing with councillor mansell
regarding the the
the junction i mean there's a very odd
statement at 14.7
uh suggesting that changing the the
junction
to um up to a priority junction would
create a cul-de-sac north of whitten
but obviously there's already a
cul-de-sac north of whitton
um created by the bus gate so it's a
very
very strange statement there and um
but i think you know stepping back a
little bit
the the inspector said yes the principle
is agreed so
our job is to get the best that we can
through through conditions and so on um
out of out of this and and
as several members have now said you
know there are some things that are just
very worrying what i would particularly
want to dwell on
is that the and this is perhaps
something for council of field and
indeed councillor hicks
the the after quite a lot of
of um of pushing uh in my ward
we we identified that a drainage
drainage problem
of flooding the road etc etc uh was
indeed due to have blocked
and i'm really sorry matterson
catholic we're not interested in your
award i'm really sorry we're talking
about the planning application before us
you could keep to the point please the
point i'm heading to absolutely for
is there seems every likely or there's a
culvert underneath this road
that is that is blocked and and
unfortunately is a very long list of
jobs like that
waiting to be done and my urgent one
that i refer to
uh is only about number 70 something in
a very long list
but on the other hand you know can we
make this
can we make it a condition somehow
the the that is found
and if it isn't found whether we can
actually put in a culvert but i'm sure
there's one there actually
we have been told we could make it we
have been told it can be part of
uh an informative note we've discussed
that already myself
stronger than not stronger than that um
not stronger than that is is there not
some way we can
we can actually make this that it's it
needs to be
solved before we actually go ahead and
build
that's that's what i'm really looking
for here i think that's
the the dominant concern and obviously i
i think that can you come in please the
future the future says we want some
different energy thank you
yes if i could just come in on the on
the surface water drainage and i
i fully recognize the strength of
feeling and i recognize that council
mayor says he doesn't think this is
reasonable
i have no i have no professional
evidence that tells me it is
unreasonable
and this is a balance of probability
judgment
and at the moment i am hearing things
about a drainage situation
at the moment i have advice from the
flood authority and advice from the
applicant's technical advisors
and if i'm really honest this is a
planning this is a consideration of a
reserve matters application
the reserve matters that we have before
us today are
not drainage just so
so we're quite clear reserve matters in
this instance include access
appearance landscaping
layout and scale
i believe fits within those reserve
matters to the extent that they may or
may not be matters of layout
and landscaping there are separate
conditions
and if members bear with me uh these
these conditions and are in the appeal
decision in your papers uh
and yeah conditions eight uh nine
uh 18 and 19 all manage surface water
drainage
now if members have a quick look at
those
they will see that they do require the
council
to agree these arrangements and i think
chairman to try and impose a condition
or to refuse an application at this
stage on that issue
i think would be unreasonable so i'm
going to take a position on that
i think what you'd suggested chairman as
regards an informant his
formative is a pragmatic solution we
don't know about the existence of a
culvert under the drain i believe sam
harvey
didn't indicate we knew there was such
an asset
we do need to ensure that this
development does not make
any surface water flooding situation any
worse
but no development is expected to solve
problems that existed before it came
along
it is only expected in to use a
euphemism to wash its own face
so we have conditions and we have
conditioned submissions which we are
looking at with the flood
authority and it is perfectly reasonable
for the committee to give us an
instruction around that you just remind
us the pages they're on i think they're
on page 120.
the version i'm looking at unfortunately
i think it's page 78 of 117 is what i
i'm i think i've got i'm not entirely
convinced because i'm i'm looking at
page 115
um so the appeal decision starts on page
115 of our papers members just so you're
aware
right okay and at the end of that there
is a list of conditions
and amongst those you have a condition
relating to
discharge of surface water into the
highway that's condition eight condition
nine is details of construction surface
water management plan so that's to
manage so that's on page 129 of our pack
i apologize i'm not i'm not going to and
then conditions 18 and 19
relate to a surface water drainage
scheme and
uh condition 19 follows along
with an implementation maintenance and
management plan and
both of those are conditions to be
resolved but this is an application for
reserve matters we are
discussing matters which i think are
within the territory of those conditions
and it's perfectly reasonable to send a
message to officers to instruct them to
ensure
this issue is looked at but i'm not
convinced that that is the territory of
this debate i'll leave it there
okay thank you very much uh councilman
did you want to come back is that an old
hand or a new hand
old hand and caster matterson old hand
okay well there's no other speakers so
i i think i think um thank you to philip
israel for just
bringing us back to what we need to
consider today
and um we have heard uh that this
obviously we do know this is a reserve
matters application and the things to
look at are the access appearance
uh landscaping layout and scale and we
have the ap
we have the appeal decision in our pack
i do want to thank belway i mean
one of my pet hates has been triple
parking and they've eliminated it
and i think that you know that shows the
power of the committee
to ask an applicant to go away and to
reconsider and and they have
in terms of the heat heating of the
properties i absolutely
uh get the point that councillor uh
manson ebern and others have made
but that is not within you know that's
not within our gift
um and uh so so you know while it may be
disappointing i accept that i i
i don't think that's a reason that i can
turn around and refuse this application
um so from my perspective um of course
um the thing i am most worried about for
me
is the existing properties and the
impact they may have from having
uh things put in place close to them so
for me i would like to see an
informative note uh
put in regards to the protection of
those properties and we'll ask philip to
cover the wording we've already covered
this off and also
um to talk about that if there is a
culvert if it could be explored if there
is one
uh that that we make sure that that is
included and those would be the items
i'd want an
informative note so as as no one else
has spoken or proposed or seconded
anything
i'm very happy to propose along those
lines
um for approval but i'm obviously up to
others
as to how they feel counselor muller yes
thank you chair i totally agree with
what you say what mr isbell says about
an informative note
therefore i am happy to second your
proposal for
um the recommendation to approve this
application thank you chair
did i just ask therefore philip could
you just run through the
what the informative note could say in
terms of wording please
thank you chairman so um what i would
suggest and i'll i'll read this long
hand because i think that
sets out the expectation so
this will be an informative note the
committee in approving these reserve
matters noted the significant concerns
of adjacent residents regarding surface
water
flooding risks and in particular the
need to ensure that surface water
drainage
uh is not impeded by old norwich road
the committee expects the applicant to
work with officers of the local planning
authority and the local flood
authority to ensure that any service
order drainage arrangements
for suds do not have any adverse impact
on the surface water flooding
situation in the locality
committee asked officers of the local
planning authority to work with the
local highway authority to establish
whether any
culvert under old norwich road exists
and requires management
or maintenance in order to prevent
surface water flooding risks
thank you sorry chairman still writing
that as we go that's fine
thank you very much okay we've got a few
more hands gone up councillor matheson e
burn and mansell
thank you chair yes uh just looking at
my notes on on the
um on the conditions um
that are suggested and so on there's a
couple of things about that
the um i think an easy one is that the
the um ecology i think ecology or
landscaping
um consulting asked that we
we specified a bio degree degradable
tree guards
i think that's that's the first which um
my understanding is that we
we should be getting at woodland trust
and so on are now
asking for those um so if that's
that was one little snippet that if we
could include
and the other one was that more perhaps
slightly more contentious and see what
others think
the parish council asked for the removal
of permitted development rights
regarding garage change of use um
this was to to make sure that they
didn't finish up with with
parking spilling out onto the norwich
road um
from the development um and um
so perhaps whether we wanted to do that
as well and i get the other question
really i think for mr isabel
was presumably the section 106 agreement
referred to at 11.2 has actually been
signed
shall i come in now chairman oh sorry
do you want me to answer some of those
questions as well
can i can i suggest um for voting
purposes mr carmichael will need the
words
so perhaps if if i if i email mr
carmichael the words mr heifer can give
you some advice on
some of those points and the section 106
for castlemaster's benefit was part of
the outline and
and the planning commission will not
have been granted without it so i'll
leave it there thank you
thank you thank you yes just on the
other
two points a councillor has raised i
don't think there's any issue at all
with the
biodegradable tree guards that that's
something we could specify within the
wording of a condition
um with regard to the permitted
development um that would
be an issue that should have been
removed outlined stage if it was felt
appropriate
i don't think we could remove it as part
of reserve matters
the only thing i would say is that as i
said in the presentation the
amount of parking that's been provided
is in accordance with the adopted
standards
so we're content that the parking
provision both for residents
and visitors does meet your standard um
but i would i would
guard against removal of pd against you
know on a reserve matters proposal
thank you councillor eben
thank you very much chair i think those
are sensible um additions um
i just wanted to query whether the it
says on the um
conditions that um following informative
notes is necessary in support for
sustainable development principles
and i just wonder if there's any way of
sort of um
boosting that in any way um how
i know that's my
we were in a committee where we had a
fantastic one and i can't
you know i can't go and quote back you
know uh
if i can remember the application number
we'll come back to that
when phillips finish writing we'll get
him to see what he is
when he's finished writing that bit
we'll come back to him thank you uh
counselor manson uh thank you chair um
i'd just like to
um uh remind people that we were also
um well there was some discussion of an
informative about suffolk county council
um looking at the bus gate issue
um and i'd also like to bring back the
subject that
when i ask the questions about the
roundabout to the highways officer
uh i got the impression that the
drawings that we've been given and that
we're actually um
determining today may not be the final
layout for the cycle lane and i and i
can't see anything
in the conditions about some sort of
uh whatever's going to happen to that
plan if it's not the plan that we've
given is that the
one that we're approving right i think
it was made clear to us actually but
we'll bring in philip is about that this
is
the standard process that goes through
it may be tweaked slightly at the end
but we'll get reconfirmation on that for
you answers
uh i'm not a councillor chairman but
thank you
getting tired no no and i'm still typing
so i'm not quite with all the questions
that have
floated out but um in in terms of the
cycling arrangements this is this will
be effectively managed under
under section 278 and it would seem to
me perfectly reasonable
to add that to the informative so um if
you're content chairman i'll continue
typing and put some suggestions
that i can then talk to you on online so
we've had it we've had a request from
council manchester about the
section 278 and the cycling we've had a
question from councillor
ebern around uh the bus gate
or so sorry someone else has talked
about the bus gate and we've also talked
about
uh can we have anything informative
about being more so
about the sustainability pushing it a
bit more
you know encouraging uh belleway in any
other way
one one can certainly do you do those
things um all i need now is a little
time to type chairman yeah no that's
absolutely fine
okay uh councillor matheson um yes i'm
not going
to do his important work getting the
words right um i
i do hope that bellway homes will take
away from this meeting
um this this committee and indeed i
think this council's
um dismay that it's not moving
in the direction that it it should be
regarding
means of heating houses we are trying to
build development for the next um
50 years not not for the next sort of
three years
and um the direction of travel is clear
thank you councilman
okay so uh when when robert is ready
uh we will ask him to read out the
recommendations along
with the informative note uh counselor
field you wanted to come in
resist being slightly controversial i
was just going to point out that some of
the concerns about um
the beltway quote about sustainable heat
are based in 2018 i think
that's three years ago and the world
moved a rapid rate and
leave you with that thought
thank you council field okay so
over to rob when you're ready
chairman you might can i suggest i'm
still typing so rob hasn't got anything
to give you
you might want to you might you might
want to hold things for five minutes
because that will probably take me that
to finish this um okay
we'll give everyone we'll start again at
five past twelve just to give you
time just to type that up and get it
over to rob
okay so we'll just run through uh what
the informative notes going to say so
over to you phillip please thank you
chairman so uh
i'd suggest the following text so the
committee in approving these
reserve matters noted the significant
concerns of adjacent residents regarding
surface water flooding risks
and in particular need to ensure that
surface water drainage is not impeded by
old norwich road the committee expects
the applicant to work with the local
planning authority and the lead flood
authority
to ensure that any surface water
drainage arrangements for suds do not
have any adverse impact upon surface
water flooding in the locality
the committee requests officers of the
local planning authority to work with
the local highway authority to a
establish whether any culver under old
norwich road exists and requires
management or maintenance in order to
prevent the backing up of surface water
and related surface water flooding risks
b establish where the cycle crossing and
shared cycle stroke footwear provision
can be made at the roundabout in estate
road junction
and c the provision of anpr
infrastructure for the bus gate
the committee moreover notes the
approach to the sustainability design
taken by the applicant and strongly
encourages the applicant to take account
of the council's direction of travel for
this
set out in draft policy lp 25 of the
draft joint local plan
and its expectations that all applicants
will recognize the importance of
improving sustainability measures in new
house design
in future applications thank you
chairman leave it there thank you very
much
uh robert over to you uh
john field cancer field sorry did you
want to come
so just with phil's words that they talk
a little about
culvert that exists and what you do we
make no requirement to ensure that if
one is required you know that they take
action um other than just establishing
whether
when the road was originally built there
was a culvert there so i wonder if we
could
strengthen that slightly without could
we say
the existing covert
i'll leave that to mr carmichael to
follow up i mean strictly speaking it's
not a it's not a reserve matters issue
i think okay so it's it's probably in
the hands of others
i understand that but it impacts
strongly residents
acceptance of development across a wide
area of the counties and i think it's
important we address this sort of issue
so robert i'm going to go over to you
can you just run through what what we're
being asked to decide today
and then if we need to tweak it slightly
we will
the microphone on so thank you chair so
um what i have proposed because there is
a slight issue in mon.gov
with the voting i can't put the whole
text in so apologies to mr isabel but it
will be added
um to the recorded vote text so i will
add that to
after the meeting so that will be
publicly available so what i would
propose
and that we do and i've put in the votes
members can see
um is that we they represent that
application dc20
03704 be approved as detailed in the
officer recommendation
with the additional informative note as
read out by the chief planning officer
if that's acceptable to yourself chair
and
your secondary
i think you're on mutual i apologize
thank you can i just ask for two things
so on the biodiversity enhancement
layout
uh which is uh uh recommendation
seven um can we just add uh and we would
ask for the use of biodegradable
um tree guards
yep i can put that in okay
um now the point that councillor field
makes
around the um
i mean sorry philip isabelle's view is
that that's not something that's really
for this committee
uh to add um but
it is a concern so
can we just ask that um
well i suppose the floods team are going
to look at that and put in appropriate
measures
so uh is there anything more we can do
philip to just
raise the profile of that because it'd
be awful if there is no culvert
and and then nothing happens
yes yeah you can you can certainly use
you can use it yes sorry what i'm saying
is you
you can't really expect it you don't
require it as a planning authority but
we can certainly
use this so um let me just get the text
up
um and this relates to the uh uh
exist so i i'd suggest it to you uh a to
establish whether any culvert under an
orange road exists and requires
management maintenance in order to print
back here
uh in order to prevent backing up social
relations and you probably add the text
in there
and i'll send this again to robert so
that robert has this
hour or whether uh or whether a culvert
should be
or whether such a culvert should be
provided might be the
additional language so if i if i add
that and send that back to robert then
he'll have that
uh for the record okay great well i
think on that basis
um we've had everything put before us
we've we've covered a lot of ground
we've added informative note on various
key subjects that concern us
um so i'm happy that we now go to the
vote that's been proposed by myself and
seconded by councillor muller
so uh robert over to you for the votes
please
thank you chair so with those changes
and i've added in on the recommendation
on modern.gov the biodegradable
three cards so if members could please
go
to the modern.gov app by pressing the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
and then clicking on the
vote which is now in progress for
this item which will be in a light blue
color
the vote has started so i will wait
for those to come in
thank you chair the vote is now being
concluded
and it is six votes for with one vote
against
thank you very much okay we're going to
move swiftly on to the next application
um which is dc 205046
land uh to the west northwest side of
barking road need a market
and i'll now hand over to the case
office jasmine wyatt to introduce the
application to committee
over to you and welcome i'm not sure if
this is your first
committee was the first time you've been
to this committee so welcome uh to our
committee and thank you for joining us
thank you very much and uh good
afternoon members
um i'll just share my screens bear with
me
right can you all see my screen
yes we can and can you see my cursor as
well just a job
yeah we can yeah brilliant okay so i'll
be presenting
case dc twenty zero five zero four six
today which is for the site land the
north west side of barking road in
needham market
this is an outline application for the
erection of 279 dwellings with access to
be considered and all other matters
reserved
members are reminded that this
presentation should be viewed and
understood in conjunction with the
committee report and it does not replace
the detail and content within that
report
so here is the site in context and the
site is outlined in red
you've got barking road located along
the
southern boundary of the site you've
then got need a market to the east
and uh the a14 and the a140 a little bit
further east as well
and then barking to the west there
the site is currently comprised of grade
two agricultural land
and the surrounding land is
significantly rural and agricultural as
you can see
in terms of the parish location uh the
site predominantly falls within
nida market uh but a small area of the
along the western side falls with
embarking
in terms of the specific location of the
site uh it would be located adjacent to
an existing residential estate along the
eastern edge of the
the site are the estate roads of
foxglove avenue which is sort of
this area along here and then that
splits off to quinton road
sort of to the north there you've then
got nida market football ground
and club which is just sort of up here
just out of sight
and the gp surgery which is just to the
south east here
and again access along barking road to
the south
so in terms of the constraints the green
area shows the extent of the gipping
valley special landscape area
you've then got the nearby heritage
assets so you have got
predominantly the list of buildings
within the conservation area along the
high street
you have got a couple of others as well
with the nearest being the grade 2
listed kennels farm
and the site falls wholly outside of but
but the uh built up area boundary of
nida market
shown by the brown line which sort of
goes all the way along the
side um the site also falls within a
mineral safeguarding area
and there is a wooded area just along
the
western edge uh with protected trees in
the barking wood barking woods triple si
is located to the south west and sort of
around here but is just outside of this
image
so giving a close-up of the special
landscape area obviously this is the
um special landscape area shown in green
and again you
sort of zoomed in this is where the
protected trees are which are all
protected by tpos
so in terms of the existing connectivity
you've got public rights away shown in
green so the
there are two bridal ways uh running
along the north
so the first one is brideaway 15 which
is also known as
the drift this thing connects onto
broadway 17 over here
and then you've got a footpath which
leads sort of further south
in towards um agricultural fields within
the parish of barking
you've then got a footway that leads
along here
and which leads again they also go to
the high street
and then the um station and bus stop
the bus stop runs from the swan uh
public house and then you've got the
railway station just sort of off of the
high street over there
um there are no cycling connections
other than
along the existing bride away sort of to
the north here
this is all uh solely pedestrian um for
uh yeah
right so in terms of uh flood risk the
southern half of the site falls within
flood zones two and three
um which shows fluvial risk as shown by
the environment agencies mapping which
is
uh these two images here the light blue
shows flood zone
two the dark blue shows flood zone three
and
using the environment agency's modeling
uh the council then produces a strategic
flood risk assessment which splits flood
zone three
into three a which is uh greater than
one in 100 annual probability of fluvial
flooding
and 3b which is the functional
floodplain which is where water has to
flow or be stored in times of flooding
it's estimated within this strategic
flood risk assessment that the site
falls within
uh 3b the southern area of the site is
also at risk
from fluvial flooding um
it's the southern area of the site is at
risk from fluid flooding but also is a
high risk from
surface water flooding and albeit to a
slightly lesser extent
as shown by the hatchet area on the
other diagram here
so the key issues i'll be discussing
include the principle of development
highways impacts and connectivity with
native market the landscape and
ecological impacts
flooding impacts and specific aspects
where
insufficient information has been
provided
so in terms of the settlement hierarchy
policy cs1
of the core strategy defines a
settlement hierarchy which identifies
that the site
falls within the countryside in an area
between the town of neda market and the
countryside village of barking
based on the site's countryside location
policies cs2 and
policy h7 are thus engaged in assessing
housing development in the countryside
whilst these may not be afforded full
weight they are still relevant and
integral considerations to the
acceptability of the principle
these policies are not however
considered in isolation and combined
with the wider basket policies as listed
within the committee report
as a whole this basket of policies are
considered consistent with the aims of
the mppf
and therefore the tilted balance is not
engaged
the emerging joint local plan allocates
three sites within need a market
um which are listed here and also shown
on this map as well
uh the site is not one of those
allocated as shown by the outline in red
and whilst this emerging plan currently
holds limited weight
it nonetheless illustrates the direction
of travel for planned growth
furthermore the submitted transport
assessment with this application
does not take this planned growth into
account
therefore should these sites be
developed in the future previously
unplanned highways mitigation may also
be required for the delivery of these
sites
needed market currently have an emerging
neighbourhood plan
which given its early stages currently
has no determinative weight
however it was noted that the
neighborhood plan makes no additional
allocations for
housing to those shown in the emerging
joint local plan
furthermore the application site is only
referenced within this neighborhood plan
in a cohesive and strategic manner in
relation to the creation of a relief
road which is shown by this black line
here which would divert traffic from the
high street to barking road
whilst this holds no determinative way
it is noted that the site would
represent
unplanned growth under piecemeal
approach to development which is
contrary to the approach adopted within
the neighborhood plan
here we have a wholly indicative master
plan which shows how 279 dwellings could
be accommodated on the site
it shows the extent of the flood zone to
the southern area just here
which includes the access which is a
matter for consideration
it is noted several of these dwellings
which are considered more vulnerable
forms of development
under the environment agency's guidance
do partially fall within the flood zones
primarily
sort of along here in terms of their
cartilage
um it is considered that these could be
sequentially cited outside of the
um flood zones two and three into flood
zone one
uh in a reserve matters application
again the site character plan is highly
indicative but provides an area on
an idea on how the development could
materialize
so 217.9 dwellings
are proposed in total and a hundred
of those would be affordables um
which is in accordance with policy and
these would be secured via section 106
agreement
the affordable housing provision is of
course a public benefit
significantly adding to the district's
affordable housing stock
this is the overall concept plan which
is again indicative
there are however some discrepancies i'd
like to point out between this plan and
the others in the previous slides
this plan shows the main access point to
the north which is misleading and has
been confirmed as solely being an
emergency access so there is only one
main access point which is to the south
here which goes through the flood zone
um furthermore a single access point
serving 279 dwellings is inadequate with
one access being considered suitable to
serve around 150 dwellings
from a highways perspective in regard to
their guidance
the sole access into the site um is
shown by the star
just here um a snippet of indicative
master plan
shows the extent of the flood zone into
the site whilst this
solely shows fluvial flood risk this
overlaps and covers the area also at
risk from pluvial flooding as shown on
the earlier slide
59 metres of the spine road inwards and
the single main access would be within
an area
at most risk and most vulnerable to
flooding
the submitted flood risk assessment uh
with the application is out of date
and dates from november 2018 and
therefore does not use the most
up-to-date modeling which was produced
in january 2020
furthermore the flood risk assessment
does not take climate change into
account
as a result they're holding objections
from the local lead flood authority and
the environment agency
as insufficient and inadequate
information has been provided
from the perspective of pluvial and
fluvial flooding
as the access runs through the
functional floodplain is wholly is a
wholly realistic prospect that occupants
any future occupants will at times have
difficulty accessing the site and could
become trapped
the creation of an access in the most
vulnerable flood zone is
unacceptable and contrary to the aims of
the mppf which seeks to steer
development away from areas vulnerable
most vulnerable to flooding
so the video i'm about to show you
starts facing westwood's along barking
road
um towards barking and sort of turns
clockwise around to show you the site
and then ends facing eastwards in to
need a market
the proposed axis would be located uh
sort of in the center of the southern
boundary of the sun would be located
just beyond the 30 mile per hour speed
limit sign here
so an emergency access is i noted
earlier is proposed to the north
however no details have been provided on
how it will be used or managed
the surfacing its width how it connects
to the highway
its effect on the bride away use and the
extent and type of the owners access
rights over private land
there is a surface section uh shown in
photos two and three which is an access
to the football ground this is however
private land
and certainly could not accommodate
traffic from 279 dwellings
faucet four shows the bride away just
beyond the turning
um into the football ground an emergency
axis in this area
would have to cross a bride away and
private land to meet the highway which
is along quinton road as shown by
photo one here the creation of an
emergency access
in this location would be wholly
unsuitable and it would be
and it would divert traffic from 279
dwellings
through a residential estate
alternatively if it was only going to be
used by
emergency vehicles then the occupants of
279 dwellings would have no means of
vehicular access in or out of the site
in the event of flooding
the bride away in any event would have
to be upgraded to a byway under a
separate consent
in order to be used by vehicular traffic
and would have to be scored prior to
determination to ensure an emergency
access could be created here
it has been confirmed that such consent
is unlikely to be granted
the creation of an emergency access in
this location
is therefore considered to be completely
inappropriate
this is the same slide as earlier
showing the connectivity within the area
the purple line
is the only edition which shows the
extent and location of the proposed
connection from the site to connect to
existing infrastructure
so a three metre shared cyclone footwear
is proposed for a short section before
this goes down to a 1.8 meter
wide footweight to connect to the
existing footwear further eastwards
adjacent to the gp surgery the start
shows where the 30 mile per hour speed
limit would be relocated to
so it would include and cover the whole
access this would be secured via traffic
regulation order
um which is a separate consent from
highways
so in terms of the existing
infrastructure um it caters primarily
for pedestrians
and the footwear um along sort of the
northern
part of barking road uh just to the side
here
um measures between 1.8 meters and 1.2
meters in width
there are therefore questions on the
quality of footpaths and how they would
cope
with increased footfall and whether they
sufficiently
would encourage the uptake of active
travel given the quality of connections
proposed
with the existing ones this this is
specifically relevant to
cyclists who save for a short proposed
section of the shared cycleway
would have to cycle on the road unless
traveling along the bride away
to the north of the site
in terms of the levels of the site there
is a 7 17 meter difference in levels
between the north and south of the site
here
so the landscape um it's very open
countryside very rural character
um the site acts as a buffer between the
urban eduna market
which is just over here and the sla
which sort of starts
uh by that wooded section over there
the council's landscape guidance
identifies the site as being visually
sensitive
acting as a rural backdrop to need a
market and as such
its development would represent an
encroachment into the countryside
in contrast to the character of the area
to the west where agricultural fields
are broken up by heavily wooded areas
this area is completely open and exposed
and thus
is very visually prominent especially
given its elevated topography
so again i have another video which
shows the elevated views from the north
of the site
and the development would encroach into
a visually sensitive gap
whilst adopting a discordant and poorly
integrated form of the existing
development adjacent
there are several aspects of the
application where insufficient
information has been provided
and as such it is reasonable for the
council to adopt a precautionary
approach in respect of these matters
the areas which lacked some of the areas
which lacked information i have
previously touched on
which include details of the emergency
access and
the flood risk impacts and mitigation
and other areas
which include the impact on future
occupants
from the noise and light from the
football ground
the mineral potential on site as it
falls within the mineral safeguarding
area
impacts on air quality from the
increased traffic and ecological impacts
and their mitigation
subsequently the recommendation is
therefore one of refusal
the reasons for which are in line with
those set out in the committee report
thank you very much and that was a very
thorough
presentation so thank you councilman you
have a question
thank you yeah there's a strange echoing
and noise at the moment chair i'm not
sure whether
it's because you're on the news yeah we
if you we'll just go to mute when we're
not speaking that should cover it
over to you drum thank you um yeah the
councilor norris or mr israel may be
able to help with this one
but the um there was a slide put up
which isn't in the papers
um of the the current condition of the
early stages neighborhood plan um
but it wasn't one that i recognized as
being
the most recent one that's been uh
consulted on in
in the town so i was a bit concerned
that that should creep into
the papers through through the
presentation
uh in the event of the possibly been an
appeal on this one
and um also just to clarify was the
the land in this special landscape area
or adjacent to the special landscape
area
thank you thank you do you want to
answer those points please
uh yeah thank you councillor matheson um
so in terms of the neighborhood plan
and this particular section i don't
think is included in the main body of
the report it's sort of an appendacy
um this is all available online
um and yeah that's that's sort of where
i've i've pulled it from is is from our
main web page on that
um in terms of the special landscape
area
the site does partially fall within the
special landscape area
it coincides with where the um woodland
area is with the
trees that are protected within it
okay thank you councillor field
thank you um just a couple of points
and things seem pretty clear but uh i
note that
um on the sort of opening page it talks
about details of previous committee
resolutions and it says none
i thought this site had been to the
committee before
uh and that we determined um
it was some constraints i just wonder am
i wrong on that
or or not um this the second sort of a
point of um
is it detail the access that you talk
about is clearly across a a flood area
um is that um
where i used to access is it level with
the existing barking road or is it
depressed so that it floods or
uh is it raised so that it doesn't flood
i mean
there's sort of details and clearly the
flood authority would have looked at
those but just for our
interest thank you
yes of course um so i'll take the first
uh sort of question you raised
in terms of the previous committee
resolutions it's not been specifically
on this application or any sort of
application
really really similar to this one in
terms of the previous application it is
noted
under the planning history um within the
committee report
but it is an application dating from
2016 which is obviously five years ago
so
policy and all the context has changed
since then
um it was a completely different scheme
i think it was for
around 150 or so um dwellings
definitely not including the whole site
um
my understanding is that the access uh
that was previously discussed within the
application
um is the same as this one and there
hasn't been to sort of answer your
second point
there hasn't been any sort of
engineering solution um
or anything that means that that access
would be raised or avoid any of the
flood waters
um i'm not sure if sam harvey might
might want to add um
a little bit in terms of the highways
impacts but that's all my understanding
of it
sam do you want to come in
yes thank you chair does basically uh
jasmine has covered it all what um the
the previous application that came in is
the same
uh for access is the same as this one
thank you just the point i was making in
a way is that uh
my memory is that the previous uh
thing was rejected or unless there was
an additional access because of the
access
the flooding issues so a bit of a
struggle to understand why we're wasting
our time with us today but uh
i'm sure that's a part of debate
okay uh i'm going to move on to cancer
plasma cancer libra and then we'll move
on can i could i can i just chip in just
as i i have happy memories of that
particular committee meeting myself
my recollection is that at the time the
application may well have been
recommended for approval
and flooding was a considerable concern
to members at the time and the
application was i think refused on on
the committee's decision rather than the
officer recommendation
that said uh obviously it was a smaller
a lesser application and
you know the the considerations and
policies at the time were different so
jasmine has
covered that thanks thank you council
password counselor eben
thank you very much matthew and um
thanks for the um presentation
jasmine uh i don't know whether you were
able to answer this
and it's not a kerbal question have you
any idea if it were to go ahead
what sort of um seal contribution might
be made that was one question
and the other question if we were if the
committee were to refuse this i know it
says on page 225
to um delegate to the chief planning
officer um
grounds for defending an appeal have we
got sufficient term
evidence and a robustness in in the
papers there to make that defense
and i know you can't guarantee anything
with a with an appeal absolutely but
would you be very confident that the
grounds that you've listed for refusal
there
would actually do the job should there
be an appeal i think that's why it's
come together i think that's why it's
before us now just to to jasmine do you
want to come in
i guess at least so in terms of the um
seal contributions i'm not entirely sure
on that point um
that's sort of an infrastructure um
perspective i don't know if phil might
have anything to add on that point
um in terms of the appeal um
obviously the reasons that we've put
before you today are reasons that we
already
feel are robust enough to defend and
appeal on um but again i'd probably
defer
maybe some further detail and question
from phil or stephen
thank you chairman if i can just simply
say
and uh i'd obviously expect my officers
to say that their reasons for refusal a
robust and defensible council pass more
um but i think we fully anticipate that
this is
this is coming and may well lead to that
consequence so we have given some close
scrutiny to
the recommendation before you the reason
for mentioning the appeal is that
there is sometimes a lag between uh the
decision at committee and the issue of a
decision notice and if that happens
we're into that mind to make a decision
world so we're just covering off that
base as we go chairman thank you
thank you uh council libern
thank you very much chair um i've just
got a couple of very quick questions
um what level of consultation has been
um carried out between um the applicant
and the planning department as it were
um to the extent that you know why we've
got so many
unanswered questions at this stage um
secondly my understanding is that an axe
for more than 150 homes there should be
two
accesses and the um
i know the football ground very well
and that access point there which um
it's
extremely busy a lot of the time and i
just wondered whether the
apt is probably a question for the
applicant whether they've had any
consultation
with the football club about access
um at that northern point thank you
chair
uh thank you council larry bern um in
terms of the level of consultation
uh no pre-application advice was sort of
sort which obviously
you know we acknowledge we can't expect
them or it's not an obligation at all
but
um the level of sort of um
i suppose consultation and discussion
has been very limited
um which is hence why there are several
sort of
um aspects which have got insufficient
information on currently
um and in terms of the level of
consultation for the emergency access
um i'm not aware of any consultation
that's happened but as you say that's
probably
um something that the applicant can
confirm thank you very much
okay thank you so we'll move on um
we don't have a representative of the
parish of needham or from barking parish
councils as it overruns into two
uh or a projector or a supporter so
we'll go straight to the agent
uh who would like to speak uh mr jason
parker uh you have three minutes to
address the committee if you could turn
your camera on please and your
microphone on
and over to you you have three minutes
thank you very much and good afternoon
everyone i hope you can hear me
um can you hear me okay yeah we can hear
you fine okay
um yes so i don't don't disagree with a
lot of what was said in the presentation
um but i'd like to go through a few
points if i may
and this is a major housing development
which could provide
up to 279 dwellings of which
100 would be affordable homes and
there isn't much mention in the
consideration of this application
in relation to the previous application
now that was for 152 dwellings
and it was refused in august 2017
um now that covered just over half of
the site and the front portion of the
site
the application was actually recommended
for approval from offices
and the committee refused that
application solely on the basis
that there was no emergency access so in
the event of a flood
the main access would be flooded
and it was felt that the school and
facilities
would be too far away now what we've
tried to do
with this application is there have been
negotiations with the joining
landowner which has resulted in a larger
application coming forward and the aim
of that it has
been to address the emergency access
issue
now we look at various options for that
and there are other options available
as well but the best solution at the
time seemed to be the
access to the top particularly as the
landowner
had a private right of way over it which
we've got details of
now taking that into account we feel as
though that dealt with the reason for
refusal
um and we've provided additional
information in terms of connectivity
with facilities of services and that
that appears in the application
information
now what what we have requested from the
planning department
is an extension of time and the
government introduced a national
extension of time process which is in
place
to allow determination periods to be
extended
and negotiations or amendments to take
place
we're really happy to do that we've
offered the extension of time
some agents say they're not prepared to
offer it we are
but unfortunately that right hasn't been
given to us
um and i feel that there are a number of
unanswered questions or technical issues
which could easily be resolved
with further information that may very
well leave the debate
there and in terms of the principle of
development but that's a debate we would
like to have with the committee
um and with the officers but at the
moment there are a number of unanswered
questions
which we feel we could easily answer
with additional information
so what i would like to request is that
the committee defers the application
we're happy to agree the extension of
time for a reasonable period of time and
beyond
and then when those matters are dealt
with it could be brought back to
committee
and we can have that discussion and
debate this is a significant
major development i would hope that the
committee will give us that opportunity
thank you
okay thank you very much uh do we have
any questions
for the agent
nope okay thank you very much thank you
for joining us our councillor field
sorry to have slow reactions uh
i i think the agent answered a number of
those issues but it's still really
unclear that there was a committee some
considerable number of years ago that
rejected a similar application
based on flooding issues and based on
the lack of a second access
i still have some difficulty in seeing
really why
those issues have not been addressed
because bringing
the thing back to committee seems
arguably to
just uh waste everybody's time and
resources so
very really clear why hasn't this been
progressed
if the applicant still intends to
continue
uh would the agent like to comment on
that
um yeah thank you and thanks for the
opportunity to comment on that and
i i did try and explain that i feel like
we have addressed the issues because
if you go back in time in august 2017
the application was recommended for
approval
now certain circumstances the heritage
or landscape of those things haven't
changed they're exactly the same
now the only reason for refusal was that
there was no
emergency access so if if there was a
flood
people couldn't get out of that area now
we feel like we've provided
that with the bridal way we can provide
additional information as well to show
that private right of way and i'm asking
for that opportunity now that was the
only reason
for refusal other than it was felt that
there may not be good access to school
facilities
now we we feel as though um
the council's policy directs major
developments to towns like needham
market
and we provide additional information in
terms of the connectivity
also the very facts that our site now
goes up to the
bridal way that enables the connectivity
as well so we feel as though we've
addressed both
issues with actually extending the
science
and offering that right away thank you
very much
okay any other questions stephen straud
you want to come in
yes good morning um cheering everybody
can
i'm gonna ask that question can you hear
me
i haven't popped up at committee for
some time but i think mindful that this
this may well end up in an appeal
scenario i am i am here and and
i've obviously been listening to uh uh
to the presentation and and
comments thus far i just wanted to come
and just clarify on the
um the point made about the historic
application from from 2016-17
um obviously and quite apart from the
fact that as as jasmine mentioned it was
a different policy context
not least the council couldn't at that
time demonstrate a five-year land supply
so of course the the tilted balance so
to speak was engaged as a consideration
and
an important consideration um looking at
the
the actual reason for the refusal
because i've got the decision notice
here in front of me
yes it is correct that it focuses on
flood risk and connectivity but also in
fact at the end of the reason for
refusal it also mentions that um
that the development would fail to
written on quoting would fail to
represent sustainable
uh development which would not conserve
or enhance the local character of the
area
so i think it's implicit within well in
fact explicit within that
reference that there are wider issues at
play which
i think picking up on councillor
passmore's uh question in terms of
robustness of appeal i think there are
some principle matters here that
effectively are not going to be overcome
and certainly not with the scale or
nature of developments being applied for
in this instance apart from any more
sort of technical matters
which are maybe capable of resolution
and which
could fall away prior to or early within
the appeal process itself
thanks okay thank you very much thank
you for adding that in
okay we don't have any other hands up so
i'll move on
oh sorry one's just gone up
i've got uh councilory burn
you have a question yes thank you jeff i
may just just um on
what following from what stephen strauss
just said um
in in the conditions it
with regards to the emergency access is
it appropriate to
to to mention the um extent of traffic
as it were that goes
um across that area
at the top of the way um going into the
football club because
you know on a on a week night you've got
you know 50 young people training there
with their parents and cars
chewing and throwing plus others um so i
just
was wasn't clear from the condition um
whether there was sufficient in that
um
stephen do you want to comment on that
with that thank you chad or jasmine
stephen or jasmine
yes i'm forgive that sorry that the lag
there no i'm i'm happy to cover that um
yes in terms of that second uh reason
for refusal it is quite long and i think
it
it would include those those various
considerations and i think as set out in
the report
which gives that sort of more
overarching basis for the reasons for
refusal
you can understand from from the higher
authority that frankly
the access proposed at that that
northern part of the site is
unacceptable
um and actually and and especially with
the advent of the new framework which
has come in post
the last application a lot of this and a
lot of the the sort of the technical
engineering evidential based
work and uh matters uh it really is a
matter of sort of
tell me show me and so much emphasis
should be placed on the onus
of an applicant putting forward that
detail and giving comfort to the
decision taker that these things can be
adequately
dealt with and that the flows of arising
from
from the development and traffic terms
can be assimilated and
frankly this this applicant application
is deficient in a number of ways
and as i say there are principal issues
but um frankly it's it's sensible to
draw a line here and make very clear in
terms of what what the various problems
are
thank you thank you very much thank you
okay we have no other
questions from members i'm sorry mr
parker
you don't get the opportunity to come
back you only get the three minutes
unless you're asked a specific question
so i can't i can't take your hand up
uh is there any other questions no
okay so um as i said uh
uh now i'll go to the ward members um
counselor stephen phillips has given his
apologies but
councillor mike norris would you like to
speak um
and then i have a statement from
councillor pratt that i'll read out so
counselor norris thank you good
afternoon
i very much support the recommendation
for refusal
uh for the reasons listed in the
planning offices report on pages 223
225 and the numerous conflicts with
mid-southwest core strategy and local
planned policies
and also with a number of the paragraphs
of the nppf
as outlined within the pages i've just
mentioned
i won't repeat them all as they're
already spelt out
as we have heard there are a number of
areas where
insufficient information has been
provided with this
within this application and for an
application
as well over the threshold of 150
dwellings there's only one main access
of parking roads shown in the indicative
site concept plan on page 339 which will
be at risk of flooding with an emergency
vehicle asset
access indicated at the northern end of
the
site which as we have heard would be
quite impractical
and that would anyway would deed
upgrading from the
present level of access they
these were elements of one of the
primary reasons for refusal of the
previous application on part of this
site for 152 dwellings under reference
3506 stroke 16.
scc highways stating their responses on
pages 265 and 266.
so i see excuse me a single access into
the site is unacceptable for a
development with over
150 dwellings proposed and because the
access point is within the medium flood
zone where there is a history of
flooding in the past there needs to be
two
permanent points of access one of which
should not be in the flood plain
and they cannot accept a single access
with an emergency access point for this
site
due to the flooding issue and they then
go on to mention other considerations
such as vehicular rights of way for the
proposed
emergency access and pedestrian and
cycle links
and they conclude by stating there is
insufficient evidence to show that any
mitigation proposals would adequately
address
the severe impact from the above points
and for this reason the county suffolk
county council
highways would recommend that planning
permission is refused on highway grants
i also support the conclusions listed by
neither market town council on pages 237
and 238
against approval of this application
including the location of the site being
outside any defined settlement boundary
the adverse impact on the local
infrastructure poor accessibility
and lack of connectivity to local
services and facilities
the paragraph headed emerging joint
local plan policies on 205 within the
planning office's report
indicates the statement includes the
statement
that the application site does not form
a proposed allocation within that
document
i.e it is anticipated that the needs of
the district can be met over the next
planned period without the
development proposed i therefore
urge the committee to support the
planning officer's recommendation for
refusal of this application
thank you thank you very much i'm sorry
councilman your hand is up i may have
missed it if it was earlier my apologies
did you have a question
no it was a question for councillor
norris chair so we're
i'm time timely um yeah okay
can you confirm that the um the
neighborhood plan
um was was um a regulation 16 submission
version um went to the district council
in october 2020
and that this didn't um include the
the diagram that we've been shown uh
during the officer's presentation
in view of what council sorry stephen
stroud has said
about the possibility of an appeal i i'm
asking whether we should not
actually totally disregard that diagram
um in making our deliberations thank you
uh
yes i has the uh regulation 16
version has recently been submitted to
mid-southwark district council
i can't remember off the top of my head
regarding the plan that you referred to
i'm sorry
i don't know whether uh stephen stroud
could
throw some light on that or
jasmine i i can uh counsellor yeah
boris um yes um i i'm aware that
the submission is to the examining
perspective is imminent or indeed has
already taken place um i haven't seen
that document but certainly in respect
of the regulation 16
consultation draft it does make
reference to
the relief road but what it's very
careful to do
is talk about the fact that that is a
long-term
sort of aim as it were which may come
into play
as uh housing needs may demand
or dictate in the future but certainly
not something that's anticipated at this
stage
and certainly not in the manner that's
proposed under this application
no agreed thank you very much thank you
so i'll now uh we'll now move on uh to
the other ward member uh from the
neighboring area
council daniel pratt and i'll read his
statement as award member for barkington
i'd like to submit concerns raised in
the representations made by members of
the parish council and the wider
community
the size of the development of 270
dwellings
would add pressures of unsustainable
growth in need of market
and would compromise the boundary to
need a market and barking
the number of homes proposed forex is
the amount needed to meet the total new
homes required
above the current land allocations for
needham market
in the emerging joint local plan
although the development boasts 100
affordable houses
the strategic housing response
highlights that the development falls
sorry fails to meet the needs of local
population
with too much emphasis placed on larger
three-bedroom dwellings
concerns regarding the impact of
additional traffic
and build up along the b1078 and the
impacts on air quality have also been
raised
also the pedestrian footwear on the
b1078 linking
needham market with barking is currently
inadequate with narrow points
and the crossings that expose
pedestrians to the dangers of speeding
traffic
the harm to wildlife arising from the
noise light and disturbances caused by
additional
traffic are likely to be understated
during and after construction
habitats found within the site includes
a block of semi-natural broadland
woodland
on the western boundary which sits
within barking among other hedges
ditches and trees within the site
concerns have also been raised on the
impact of wildlife in the
triple si priestly woods embarking
located
circa 800 meters away from the proposed
development site
the bridal way br15 could be made unsafe
and unusable for walkers
cyclists and other users if large
volumes of traffic were to be diverted
onto it as pointed out by the officer
for green access there is very little
evidence to show
that it can be restricted for use in
emergencies only
this is harmful and counterproductive to
our aims to encourage the use of paths
for active travel and recreation the
site sits in a moderate to high
probability flood risk zone and concerns
have been raised around the impact of
the development
to flooding on the b-1078 the b-1078
already suffers frequent flood events
embarking
climate change could worsen the
frequency and impact of flooding at
several locations on the road
between barking and needham this
proposal does not meet the needs of
residents locally particularly to
younger people needing an affordable
home
or to people wishing to downsize it is
totally unsympathetic to its
surroundings
causing harm to natural environment
comprising and sorry compromising
access to and oh sorry
let's read that again it is totally
unsympathetic to its surrounding causing
harm to the natural environment
in comprising access to and enjoyment of
footpaths
and views of woodlands and agricultural
land it is not adequately supported by
schools and health services
therefore i request the planning
committee to consider refusal of this
application
okay so that's uh from the ward members
so it's really over to us now to discuss
debate and come to a conclusion
councillor matheson your hand was up
first or was that an old hand then
councillor field
councillor field you're first up
thank you i have to say
that i do think that some of the
suggestions that need a market lacks
facilities and can't support housing
growth
uh stretches one's imagination a bit
when we look at
areas like thurston that support that
are a village and support
vastly greater growth having said that
the the officers recommendations seem
absolutely clear
highways have suggested that we reduce
this
development and highways don't do that
very frequently
the requirement for a second access
again is
totally clear it's there it's not been
there's sort of a vague idea that it
might be possible to use a bridal way
but there is just no clarity there
there's
nothing has been absolutely determined
so i don't see any opportunity to do
anything but go with the officer's
recommendation
and refuse this application and i
propose that
is the action we take thank you very
much thank you
councillor mother thank you chair i
totally agree with what uh coach lefield
has said and i'm more than happy to
second his proposal
to support the officer's recommendation
for refusal on this application
thank you councillor passmore uh thank
you matthew um i'm going to follow him
behind both of the uh
both of the previous council speakers um
yes we do need economic development
growth but it does need to be planned in
the right way this is an enormous
application
and i'm afraid um having considered the
arguments and heard all the points
i too i'm going to vote to oppose this
it's out of proportion yes there might
be economic gain but there are too many
questions and things that i think are
flawed in this application so i should
be supporting the
recommendations of the officers to
refuse it thank you councillor
uh thank you uh yes i too um share the
views of the three councillors who've
spoken before me
um but i i would just like to comment
that i'm i'm a little confused by the um
the agent or the applicant's comment
that he felt that this
plan had addressed the issues that we
raised in the
um one that we determined back in 2017
um when of course we didn't have a
five-year land supply
uh and we were concerned then that we
had an access over flood ground for
uh 152 houses here we have almost twice
as many houses
and we've still really only got one
access um
it uh you know although he said oh
we've got an emergency access we have no
guarantee we have no details of that
emergency access and from all the
information we've been given today
it looks like it is an unviable
secondary access
um so i have i have no qualms about um
going along with the office of
recommendation like the other
councillors have already spoken thank
you
thank you uh councillor mayor then
councilor matheson then we'll go to the
vote
thanks chair um fully supporting all the
comments made by
previous councillors uh i think the the
report by the officer was excellent i
think the justification
of the position that they're
recommending is very robust
and i'm very happy to support uh the the
officer's recommendation
thank you very much and then councilor
matheson yes quite agree i just wondered
whether officers would
agree we should include um the fact that
the
um the emerging neighborhood plan
um does not favor this development
uh regulations 16 etc stephen do you
want to come in on that
yes sure i suppose part of the problem
with that is that um
the neighborhood plan is not as of yet
part of the development plan
and it's it's still at an early stage of
the plan making process and the
the views of the examining inspector are
awaited
um so i think it would be uh unwise to
place undue weight on that plan at this
stage
but that's not to say that once an
appeal is if it is in and if an appeal
is in
that of course as that plan makes more
progress and potentially becomes a
post-examination plan
we could then seek to
effectively not necessarily amend our
our case but
incorporate what would be a very
important new material consideration
of course the inspector would have to
have regard to isolation
okay thank you okay so it's been
proposed by council of fields and second
by council mueller
as per the recommendation i'm going to
hand over to
robert carmichael
sorry chair i was having trouble getting
off mute so if members could please go
to the modern.gov app
and go to the plus in the top right hand
corner
and then please go to the attendance and
voting and
the vote will be shown in a light blue
color
under the application for today and i
have started the vote
robert i think we just need to be clear
that if you vote for you're voting for
refusal
yes uh just to be clear i put it in the
i've worded it that application dc
20.05046 be refused as detailed in the
office recommendation
yeah so you're voting for refusal or
against refusal or abstain
thank you
thank you chair those have now all come
through and that is unanimous vote for
refusing the application okay
thank you very much um okay just
finishing up um
[Music]
we don't have any site inspection
requests to be reported to committee do
we
robert i'm sure we don't no chair nope
okay so i formally closed the meeting at
1305. thank you everyone much for
joining us and
can i thank those uh from outside of mid
suffolk who also
came along to the meeting today thank
you very much thank you very much
you